I have some tour dates to let you know
about Athens Georgia on November
7th and Atlanta Georgia November 29th
and 30th at the Fox Theater get your
tickets at theovon
docomo we got new merch three new shirts
you can check them out uh they're
beautiful they're nice if you're getting
somebody a Christmas gift this could be
one get on it early Rat King America
gang gang palm and the hitter 500 racing
get that and more at theovon store.com
thank you so much for the support
today's guest is a journalist political
commentator
author and just damn yapper he's one of
the guys that uh that has made a big
transition recently from going to a
major Network to um onto X which is a
major network but it's a little bit
different uh you guys know him probably
by name and if you don't you're going to
get to um today's guest is is Tucker
[Music]
Carson I'll sit and tell you my
stor
sh on
me and I will find a song I will
[Applause]
sing insert is in or you need a spit
cup yeah you got to try this product
it's unbelievable maybe I'll try one
towards the end of the episode it will
wind you up really yes once you try this
you're going to get a lot richer Zen is
that their advertising campaign Zen is
not a sin that's the advertising
campaign really yeah but the truth is
Zen is a powerful work enhancer and also
a male enhancer if you know what I mean
really talking erection huh yep there's
no election for it with Zen
wow I don't know if I want a Zen
supported wiener you know I don't know I
think you do I think you you think so oh
yeah cuz you want people to get addicted
to Just Close Your
Eyes oh damn it's like that that's the
neighbor saying hey it's real quiet over
there just whack it on the
[Music]
nightstand ah sorry excuse me sorry dude
I would hate to have a real long wiener
if you have a cat that would be the
that would be the be dangerous
it would be dangerous talking about a
cat
toy oh yeah but you'd have to put a
little bell at the end of it or
something you a feather yeah um nice to
meet you man we never
met dude you have such a crazy you have
a crazy laugh don't you it's real it's
beautiful it's beautiful I shouldn't say
that it's very hot is this are we on TV
huh is this being recorded yeah yeah so
my laugh is very high and that's how you
know that it's real because it's so
embarrassing and I do it anyway I like
that yeah and I shouldn't have said that
it's not nice to condemn somebody's
laugh or whatever oh I you can't hurt my
feelings okay go ahead and try oh I'll
give it a run man okay good um no I
think you're laugh it kind of reminds me
of like a like a proud kind of
Grandmother from like maybe the
1850s or something maybe totally sending
her boys off to
war
or like a woman that just got a new
cookie recipe in the mail you
know it's joyful but there's a sort of
undertone of diabolic oh yeah yeah but
in my case it's totally it's totally
real and again it's not an appealing
laugh it's not like wow what a manly
laugh that is it's not a chortle it's
more a giggle yeah yeah no it seems like
a kid yeah like a kids would love it it
seems like um but not too much yeah it
reminds me of like Winnie the Pooh kind
of you know you you low key do have a
Christopher Robin Vibe if he grew up you
know thank you I don't think he ever did
though really I think he exists only in
the pages of the books oh yeah actually
there was a Christopher Robin that was
mil's son and he grew up to be a super
bitter bitter atheist who hated his dad
uhuh yeah it didn't work really it's all
fantasy yes wow unless I miss
remembering that AA Millan who wrote the
book yeah he had kind of a tragic family
life oh that's
heartbreaking um good see today man we
never met before one of my children is
like your biggest fan really yes and are
they like how children are we talking
mid 20s oh that's fine I'm just saying I
don't want yeah I don't nothing creepy
or anything that I don't need like
because it's kind of weird that they
allow like little kids to watch you CE
that like sometimes it's weird that
there's no barrier to entry in a lot
porn on Twitter dude so I mean in a
world that allows that you're fine you
think there should be porn on Twitter no
no it shouldn't be porn on Twitter I
mean I'm you know no yeah don't go to TW
mean I don't I mean I wouldn't you know
spend a lot of time trying to ban porn
on Twitter but like porn on Twitter come
on yeah Twitter is for your ugly
opinions not you know not your nudity
yeah um what things do you think
shouldn't be on
Twitter I mean I think everything should
be allowed on Twitter I mean I'm on
Twitter because everything is allowed
right um I don't think everything is
allowed on Twitter I haven't found the
boundary yet but but Elon Musk who owns
it has said he's for free speech and if
it's a political view that most people
don't like it's still allowed yeah and
I'm so grateful for that as someone with
unpopular views you know well didn't
they have well one thing that I don't
like on Twitter sometimes you see like
people beating up teachers and stuff
like that you ever seen any of this
violence that happens I don't like it
but the fact that they allow it and kids
beating up each other they have like
those things where somebody's going to
set up a somebody's filming some other
kids like are going to come in and beat
up the kid right um but why do they
because then I feel like if they would
stop allowing that then because other
kids just start mimicking what they see
well it's also bad it's bad for you to
watch it I say someone who's watched a
lot of it it's like the Isis videos do
you know what I mean or there's a whole
bunch of channels of criminals getting
shot coming into a jewelry store or a
liquor store and some Korean guy just
blows them away and you can't help but
love it I mean it is the most alluring
kind of porn you just watch it again and
again this guy getting killed yeah and
you think this is not good for me
actually I shouldn't watch this yeah
there's probably part of your spirit or
whatever totally it's not edifying it's
it's like actually bad but it's very
hard have you ever seen the criminals
getting killed oh yeah yeah I've seen a
couple of them there's one guy who's so
good at it he's killed like seven
criminals yeah he he's a watch maker in
la oh is he yeah no it's a very famous
guy oh there's a one guy I'm like dude
they got to quit trying to rob this guy
well he finally gave up and now I think
he lives in Vegas but this was in the
80s or '90s in La I think he killed five
people literally with revolvers too this
was this was before everyone had like a
double stack you know 19 round magazine
these were just like with conventional
38 or 357 revolvers that's him right
there can you have that up for me Nick
this is a um yeah watch seller he's
actually a watch maker he's the guy who
you know fixes expensive watches and
makes the new gears he's a very yeah
look at that Mr Thomas the dealer Lance
Thomas was wounded five times at his
shop Wow Let's see he's like the 50 okay
I'm I'm sorry it's my memory pretty good
or what he killed five robbers since '
89 that's amazing he's like the 50
Center watchmaker he's like 50
seconds he's like okay that's good okay
that dude's unreal they ran me out of
business timeas says there's got to be a
truth there's got to be a
time there's got to be a time when you
walk away from the war zone wow so he
just quit because it was too what a BMF
I mean he just yeah he shot a couple in
one
day he says this is his best quote Mr
Thomas said he felt No Remorse for the
lives he had taken the police ruled each
shooting was justified I was Ice he said
a frightening thing about this is that
it all becomes easier wow it's not good
for you to I mean you don't want to have
to kill five people I don't you know I
don't think it's I don't think it's good
for you what's a fair amount of people
to kill I don't think you want to kill
anyone if you can help it you know I
mean well it's certainly justified in
self-defense I mean no one will judge
you no no honest person will judge you
for killing someone to protect your life
or your loved on
even your property but I just don't
think you want to have to do that yeah I
agree I I mean well unfortunately
there's some people I think that wake up
and they're kind of like kind of looking
you know wouldn't mind getting into a
little you know killing or whatever but
I think yeah I think you have a lot of
people move into places where you can
defend yourself where the laws are more
in your favor to defend yourself because
it feels like your own safety has become
your own responsibility well you can't
defend yourself you're a slave I mean by
definition if someone can hurt you but
you can't defend yourself then you're
not a human being you're you're subhuman
obviously yeah like cuz that that's a
human right that precedes government
right I mean being a human I def
defending yourself you know you have to
be able to defend if I walk up and punch
you in the face and you can't hit back
I'm the master you're the slave
obviously yeah you know yeah that's why
I think it's one reason why you can't
take guns away is because people have at
the end of the day have to be able to
defend themselves or groups of people
have to well of course and the police
you know they've got their own thing
their own concerns and yeah you can't
rely on them um but I was thinking yeah
what I don't like about those vi like
the violence that they show on Twitter
where it's like the children beating up
children is because if you're a kid and
you see that and you see it gets a lot
of traction then you just go do it so
you're just replicating this VI like
that it's like you see so many more kids
doing it now because they've seen it as
like a thing like so that kind of thing
I don't think they should allow on there
well also you don't want to see every
ugly thing that people do you know what
I mean mean yeah you don't want to see
fat people in the shower you don't want
to see people on the John like there are
a lot of things that happen that you
don't necessarily want to look at video
of I don't mind watching a thick person
in the shower if there's a real skinny
person there with them and they have to
like kind of like jockey for position or
something you know shower with
somebody's hard I think I don't know
matter what size they are have you seen
a lot of that I think I've I've been in
some showers with them you know with
varing sizes of humans and yeah it's
always what's the fattest person you've
showered
with oh a
[Music]
good I'm trying to remember real fat or
just kind of bulky I remember I picked
this gal up one time trying to
go back to how it felt on my
back um I'd probably
say upper ones upper ones but you're not
going to I wouldn't get into that no no
no no just
is it okay you're lying I can tell
yeah yeah you
are okay
no is there laws like do you know if
there's any laws like if there's people
who are doing pedophil right and they
are reaching out to Children through
social media why isn't there a
responsibility on the social media
companies allowing that to be a open
wall I think there is I think there is
and I think some have got in trouble for
that oh okay providing a space that um
look I'm not a I'm not a lawyer uh but
it's certainly wrong certainly immoral
yeah and I and I you know I you got to
think they make some effort to stop that
though I think there's there's a lot of
there a lot of creepy people out there
yeah and the number of creepy people is
increasing you think so seems to be yeah
seems to
be yeah I wonder why that is huh because
you can look up other creepy people it's
kind of like you said you wouldn't allow
video of kids fighting on the internet
because it inspires other kids to fight
I think you know creepiness inspires
creepiness right yeah that's a good
point um yeah man I just want to get to
know you a little bit I want to get to
know you too and not like the whole
shower thing oh no out no no you don't
weigh enough I don't think close for
what I'm looking for
okay um yeah man nice to meet you so you
grew up you grew up in California right
I did and so were you I think people
were you in a fraternity I think that's
the most thing people look at when they
see
was really no okay I never joined a
fraternity all my roommates joined a
fraternity I actually lived in a
fraternity but I never joined and I
don't like to be told what to do at all
really no me neither dude like at all
like at all at all yeah yeah it's my big
it's like I have a moral claustrophobia
about being told what to do I'm happy to
do things I don't mind serving other
people but it has to be voluntary I
can't be ordered around yeah I don't
like being told what to do hey go
get me a cigarette you're a pledge you
don't think so yeah that's a good point
I don't think not going to do that yeah
and I don't want to be told what to do
by some white kid that's in uh polyi or
whatever or any color kid no color kid
yeah yeah or adult for that matter I
just don't want to be bossed around and
by the way I don't mind taking advice or
wise counsel from people I respect or
I'm often wrong I'm not saying that I'm
always right I'm definitely not but
being ordered to do things suggests a
level of disrespect I just can't I just
can't deal with it at all and even just
about like work and stuff were you
always like that from just like with
work like you want to be your own voice
of course yeah I mean I keep where you
end up right getting fired right yeah
yeah I mean not that I don't I don't
want to fight about it I'm not
interested in being like you can't tell
me what to do or you know give a lot of
lectures about it but I I def especially
in my business you have a similar job
where you know you're paid to say what
you think yeah right and so you you want
to do your job which is to say what you
think was there even a time when you
were working at different news places
where you were like gosh this still
isn't my own voice oh all the time
really was always my own voice but there
just you could feel the parameters I
mean I started in my 20s mid 20s I'm now
in my mid-50s so it's been a long time
why you look great for 50s man I'm 54
are you really yes oh wow I know isn't
that shocking it's shocking I don't feel
it but anyway but when you're when
you're much younger you've got little
kids I always had a lot of kids just
reproduced like a crazy person yeah
which I recommend strongly to you um you
know you feel vulnerable and like you
know you're not allowed to say certain
things and I do think I I was never
censored but I self-censored for sure
you know the Warner rock breaks out and
you're like maybe it's a good
idea but it's not a good idea and you
know it's not a good idea yeah you know
what I mean but you allow yourself to be
convinced because you know it's super
unpopular to say it's not a good idea
but it clearly wasn't war with Iran not
a good idea I can say that now why do we
go along with that consensus a lot of
times what is it that makes us afraid to
speak out well people have a deep need
to be part of a group it's just it's a
human need right up there with sex and
food and shelter you know it's like
people want to be connected to other
people which I understand and and I want
that too but that can override reason
and Common Sense very often so if you're
I know million studies been done on this
but if you're in a group I mean everyone
experienc a group full of people and
everyone's like you know I hate
chocolate ice cream and you're like I
kind of like chocolate ice cream but you
don't say anything about it cuz people
like chocolate ice cream suck and you're
like yeah they kind of suck you know
it's just it's a human thing and um so
it's people go along with stuff that
their gut tells them isn't the right
thing but you should never ignore your
gut your instincts which you inherited
from your ancestors which are encoded in
your DNA and which are almost never
wrong if you're with someone and you
feel like God that person's lying that
that person's lying you may not know
what about you don't have X-ray vision
into someone's soul but you can smell
the deception on someone I know that you
can we all can oh yeah or if you feel
danger you're like wow this person poses
a threat to me you're
right you don't know the details you
don't need to know the details get away
and if something's really stupid like
let's go over a war with ran it's like
what yeah and I just feel like it's you
know maybe because of my age and my job
I I have a moral obligation to say I I I
think that's really unwise you don't
want to you don't want to go to war with
Iran no because I'm not insane that's
insane oh yeah look I'm not saying it is
either I don't think that we should be
involved in a lot of this you think
how's it helping is it helping you a lot
no it's just causing all these moral
victories you're winning it's causing
more problems I don't even know if I'm
winning any moral victories it just
causes more problems you know it's like
hard to navigate between my friends that
are different ethnicities or different
or from different places now it's like
shouldn't have to cuz we all live here
and we're all we should all be United in
that right but do you think and I think
when I when I was a child it felt like
that we were
all it felt like we were United that we
were all like Americans but it
doesn't I feel like that's been pretty
heavily compromised pretty quickly even
which is almost amazing and I feel like
um and these aren't Debbie Downer
feelings these are just thoughts I
should say that I think sometimes that
yeah it's like like America just feels
like a shell company yes that
um that uh people just park their assets
an LLC for for the world for a lot of
yeah no have we always been that though
of course not it was a real country it
wasn't just an idea or some shell
company or LLC that's so nice I'm
stealing that by the way I hope this
never airs so I can steal that yeah but
no a buddy of mine one of my best
friends just sent me video about 8
minutes ago he's dropping he's visiting
his daughter at parents weekend out of
college a well-known college and there's
a huge demonstration in the middle of
Campus between you know two sides in the
Middle East M and one of the sides
starts burning the other side's flag
it's a foreign flag okay okay and this
fist fight breaks out and I'm like I
mean I have views on you know who's more
right or whatever but I thought to
myself and I said to him if someone
burned an American flag nobody would
fight over it you get to burn the
American flag but burning the flag of
another country which is not our country
to which we do not pay taxes whose
military we don't serve in that's the
most offensive thing I'm like we have
lost the thread man we're all Americans
and if you wind up in a place where our
allegiance to other countries or regions
or things that are not American take
precedence over our common
americanness I mean we're screwed we're
screwed I feel like we're at the Apex of
that sometimes yes and if we're not at
the apex apex of that I don't think in
the can't tell if we're at that in
the I think we're getting to that in the
moral compass of a lot of people yeah
and it's sad because I think a lot of
people myself included or for myself I
don't think I ever wanted to get to that
place no I never but I think a lot of
people are just starting to feel like um
you know once your americanism like dis
dissolves and once your like Common
Thread dissolves you don't have a
connection you know and so then you it's
your instincts start to take over like
we're kind of talking about and you have
to take care of yourself and so once
like the ice you're on starts to get
melding like before you're on an ice you
can skate you're seeing other people
you're do you know you're buying
a you know bootleg Gretzky Jersey off
somebody whatever you guys are all on
the ice right you're imitating Home
Alone there's a you know gays
are there's gay guys always on the ice
but it's like um what are the gates
doing on the ice do you think skating
bro yeah stupid but they're having fun
right I live and I'll say that I live
live with a gay ice skater and he could
jump over a Volkswagen right that's
impressive oh it was unbelievable bro
I'd never seen that how strong ankles I
mean just the dude was like a um
yeah he brought us out of the living
room once and showed us and blew our
minds man beautiful guy not that I mean
pretty beautiful I guess tall tall which
adds a little bit well built too
obviously oh yeah kind of I don't know
I'm GNA quit thinking about him but um
but anyway but once that ice starts to
melt the first thing you have to think
about is yourself right and so that's
what I feel like we're at now and a lot
of people are having to think about
themselves like literally watching our
country or what we viewed as our ideals
and morals and what we held dear like
sink in this water and there's nothing
you can do about it except take care of
yourself that's why I feel like a lot of
people are at there's nothing they can
do right now but take care of themselves
and they're displacing a lot of their
frustration about our economy which we
never talk about it's getting very
expensive people to live here like too
expensive actually oh yeah I saw some G
the other day I was like jeez Jesus man
how do people afford that you know how
do you even do a bonfire anymore you
know totally right no it's completely
right how do you if you want to take you
know gasoline import on the pallets like
it's six bucks you know right but um but
they're displacing a lot of that
frustration onto regions countries
conflicts that are thousands of miles
away it's almost like I'm picking a team
and all my rage is going to and I do
wish people Reserve their anger for our
leaders who deserve it in my opinion on
both sides and for the problems that are
like besetting the country you drive
through America recently it's like not
in good shape at all it's kind of poor
actually shockingly poor and um people
should be really mad about that and
instead they're mad about whatever
Israel Hamas I mean I get it I I I think
they're you know I understand people are
upset on both sides however you it's
unhealthy to be spend all your time in
your head enraged about a foreign
conflict when your own country is
suffering so badly like we need that
energy that constructive energy here and
I never hear anybody say 108,000 people
died of fentel odas last year in my
country oh like young people a lot of
whom weren't doing fentel they were
taking peret or benzo and they ingested
a pill with fenlin and they died they
were poisoned to death okay that's
unbelievable that's outrageous no one
seems mad about that yeah they're mad
about some foreign war and what a waste
you know cuz we can't control that
anyway yeah what do you call a person
who speaks three languages
trilingual maybe or thril lingual I'm
not sure what do you call a person who
speaks
to not me that's it but if you are like
me and you want to learn more languages
well Babel can help that's right only
22% of Americans speak a language other
than English at home start learning a
new language this fall and be the
exception because with Babel you start
speaking a language in just 3 weeks
why Babel because it works Babel is
designed by real people for real
conversations all of Babel's tips and
tools for learning a new language are
approachable accessible rooted in real
life situations and delivered with
conversion-based
teaching that's right and here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right
now get 55% off your Babel subscription
but only for our listeners at babel.com
tho get 55% off at
babbel.com Theo that's
babbel.com
Theo rules and restrictions May apply
there are some famous comedy Duos who
get it done you know that I'll say Key
and
Peele um Brook and
Mortal um Santino and Lee those are some
but the perfect Duo when it comes to
Growing your business is you and Shopify
that's right when I started uh
podcasting um having an online store was
kind of the fur Furthest Thing from my
mind I didn't think about it I didn't
expect it you know and uh all that's
changed over time and Shopify has helped
that's right Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage to the
first real life store stage all the way
to the did we just hit a million orders
stage they're all waiting for you and
Shopify is there to help you grow
whether you're selling scented soap or
Menthol just pure Menthol in a can
Shopify helps you sell
everywhere Shopify can help you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting check out checkout
up to 36% better compared to other
leading Commerce platforms that's right
right now you can sign up for a $1 per
month trial period at shopify.com
Theo that's right go to Shopify
shopify.com
tho now to grow your business no matter
what stage you're in shopify.com
Theo yeah well I think it's it's a lot
it's I mean that opioid epidemic thing
you know like I remember watching that
show what was that show that I really
liked yeah dopesick you see dopesick no
man I don't know if I could handle it
but I I live in a place with a lot of
that so I see it well it's about the F
it's about Michael Keaton is in it right
I think that's him he used to be Batman
but now I guess he's selling drugs right
which is a perfect example oh it's it's
about puru Pharma it's a perfect example
of our country even Batman is
selling pills you know well the company
that got the country got Rural America
hooked on opioids got away with it I
mean they nobody went to jail yeah the
Sackler family they're still they're
still rich and like really didn't go to
jail that's what this this ruined my
this ruin
this I think about this every single day
I hate the Sackler family I hate this
whole thing that happened it's
unbelievable but they got away with it
how do you do that well these people
this country they they let a our FDA let
these people down but no one was
punished not one person was punished
yeah I know and you see people go to
jail I mean this not even a political
point it's true on both you know voters
for both parties go to jail for very
small things very small things and yet
you like poison the entire country you
wreck an entire generation of kids and
you're still a billionaire tell me how
that works I don't know if I ever saw
that guy on the street I would
saw his face off how would you saw his
face off I'd figure it out do you do you
bring a saw do you have a saw with you
i' just turn into a saw that's how how
much I hate that
guy you know I mean it's just
unbelievable how many people I got
killed in no care concern no and then
the way that they lobbied our own FDA
people they took them off of the job and
paid them more to work for them to help
them beat the laws yeah sorry man I
didn't mean to bring that up no no no
but I mean next time they tell me I have
to take some Pharma product I'm probably
going to pass I'm just saying yeah I'm
probably going to pass I don't trust you
anymore sorry well I miss the days you
can get some good pills too I
mean there's part of that in this you
know when a dude could give you a couple
stack or twos you know you'd hold up the
wall over there in uh in hoken for an
hour you know I think those days are are
are over you got to go to fenel I just
don't want to do it no I don't think you
should well I'll overdose man I'm so I'm
sober like 18 months I would overdose
easy You're Sober 18 months one of the
reasons I don't do cocaine anymore is
because they ruined it why with
the fenyl used to be this baby laxative
yeah but I'd rather than die you
know I agree with that completely you
know I'd rather get off the toilet and
be like oh that was hectic than be like
you know laying there just like God wish
I could blue yeah but I got to go
to heaven and that and that by the way
is a
guess okay but um that's the hope but so
how's it been 18 months it's been good
man I love it you know how were the
first six weeks that's the toughest part
oh I know I've been there oh you have
yeah what did you have to get off of oh
you name it yeah it's been 21 years but
yeah but you still you can drink
though I can I can do a little blow I
can drink but other than that I'm
totally sober yeah it's it's a modified
who your sponsor Shephard Smith that's
what I want to
know okay that's funny but I'm not going
to comment on it beyond that that's fine
um no and no dig to Shepherd I'm a fan
of Shepherd yeah yeah yeah but he's just
a legend in a lot of circles from a lot
of friends of mine from different
colleges how do you how do you know all
this it's like dude it's easy you just
be alive and you just pay
attention well without commenting on
that I will say uh but no SOB's been
cool for me man but it was tough the
first six weeks like how what you do
yeah I think what's tough is like uh
having to change having to quit
something you know having to not have a
beer if you need it having to not like
have something to give me a little bit
of respit from my own angst yes that's a
lot of it did you go off everything yeah
so I didn't have a problem with any
thing except for cocaine so if I drink I
could have a drink I'd be fine I hated
drinking but I know if I have a drink
the only reason I'm going to have it is
so I can go I'll have four sips and then
I'll go get some cocaine and then I'll
be how did you deal with feeling
terrible the next day on the cocaine
yeah oh poorly brother begging people
for Gatorade over text message yeah it
was horrible dude yeah and this this was
some of this they didn't have that it's
it's a high cost drug yeah and not just
on the front end on the back end yeah
the next day was horrible the sad like
the things I have to apologize for yeah
what's the freakiest thing you did while
in cocaine oh dude I'll tell you some
well the weirdest thing is what I I
would look for escorts on the internet
right well and classic cocaine move
there yeah dude Hunter Biden is plowed
this Furrow
before others others have been where you
were yeah yeah yeah um literally yeah I
think Hunter even was my plug on some of
this and so he uh I would but then they
would come
to my residence I would be so scared and
paranoid I would take the money and hand
it out the door cuz I didn't want to not
pay for
the you know I you know they drove over
right you know so yeah I would pay him
and then I would just be grateful that
they weren't there so you you wouldn't
stiff the hooker but then you wouldn't
stiff the
hooker well played
brother I think look I well I just felt
bad I did you must have been their
account well then sometimes dude I had
to talk to a lady who speaks another
language that's crazy cuz then you're
playing charades you're high on
cocain you were ordering the human
trafficking ones I wouldn't say that
dude these people were off the
interstate I would say that they were of
the inter yeah they weren't like what
they call them lot lizards no this was
out of this was I mean they weren't I
think these were decent ladies who were
totally trying to make a dollar I never
yeah anyway this didn't get end well but
but yeah that was this that was kind of
the toughest part cuz I was just looking
for some kind of connection of course
and I just that's a real thing what you
just said I get that I didn't know how
to get it because it's isolating it's
drugs and alcohol are isolating you're
you're really about yourself when you're
doing them and part of you wants to
reach out and connect with someone else
I think that's Absol I think that's
absolutely right yeah I I like cocaine
because I needed to control how I felt
immediately that's one thing reason I
didn't like alcohol cuz I I was just
such a control person person that I
needed to control how I felt immediately
so cocaine I could do it immediately I
would the feeling would be there
immediately yeah um and so that's one
reason that I liked it but you never got
into Xanax or alcohol or anything to
help you come down no I wish I had I
didn't know you could do that oh yeah
you can do that I mean I don't think
it's legal but you can so I was doing
yeah yeah you're doing it wrong I was
just you had the wrong kind of cocaine
addiction and most of the I was
doing I think it was Sherwin Williams
you know this had you know I
remember doing an eightball of matte
finish you know so I'm like this isn't
legitimate you know some semi gloss I'm
like this is for shutters this
is outdoor with it you know I've done
some very questionable cocaine you know
so uh what was it like for you getting
getting off of it I mean it was awful it
was awful it was awful it was it was
absolutely awful um but I'm so grateful
that I did I'm I'm thankful my brother
and I both did actually wow so it's in
your family it's a gene it's a well it's
in my family we're Swedish yeah oh yall
are yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
I'll the farther north you go in on the
globe the higher percentage of people
have drinking problems I mean that's I
think pretty well established fact look
at Santa do works one day A year
I mean the eskimos no I'm serious and
you know oh yeah a lot of ancestors from
northern Europe so yeah alcoholism is a
big thing and I needed to get off it and
uh had children and a job on TV and it's
just not compatible with a productive
happy life at all and I I quit and the
first few months were like shocking I
didn't realize I didn't real well I had
no help at all really yeah I didn't I
did it at home alone you not willing to
try and have like were you that kind of
like you're like were you a like well I
had a public job you know I was an
anchor on CNN and so I just thought I I
don't want to get into the whole like
I'm going to rehab or whatever I just
didn't want to get involved with that
and it was fine it worked great
and I've never you know gone back and I
I never would at for anything however I
didn't realize that I knew very little
about about it I hadn't this was kind of
before I was using the internet I just
didn't know that much about addiction at
all and I quit and all of a sudden I had
these withdrawal symptoms that were like
shocking my hands are shaking I feel
like I'm going to freak out all the time
super anxious super super anxious
sweating heart palpitation
I was like what is this and I asked
somebody I didn't tell many people but I
asked somebody like oh you're
withdrawing from alcohol and if you
start to hallucinate that means you have
the DTs the delirium tremens and you
need to go to the hospital because you
could die I was like what I never got
that thank heaven but uh anyway yeah I
was awful but then you know within
like I don't know 6 months I felt great
I started smoking two cigarettes at once
I mean my nicotine nicotine PR got a
little more intense but uh but I felt
wonderful and I felt great ever since
wow and did you ever go to minis did you
ever get into a 12 step or no not one
time but I love it I have I was had just
had dinner last night with Bobby Kennedy
who's been in 12-step program Russell
Brand same thing another friend of mine
I almost almost went to a meeting at
Bobby's house on Tuesday oh okay then
what a what a wonderful man he is Bob's
a neat guy isn't he he is he's a very
deep person and he's learned the right
things and people like that make me very
Pro 12 step CU like they're they're just
like I'm not in control of my life and
they're not because nobody is everyone
lies about it I've got it under control
no you don't you no freaking idea what
you're doing you can't extend your life
by a single day you're lying to yourself
and those around you just admit you have
no clue you're doing the best you can
you're a totally screwed up kind of
embarrassing person you know what I mean
okay and be liberated and so I strongly
believe in that because it's true it is
the truth I know and the rest of it is
such a such a sled we pull and
fake it's ridiculous as I always say to
my kids everybody knows who you really
are everybody already knows what your
bad qualities are and they love you
anyway so don't even try and hide them I
mean I'm sure you know people who are
like alcoholic or bad temper secretly
gay or what and yeah they're like oh no
one knows no one knows it's like
everybody knows you kidding and and
again they love you anyway so you don't
need to hide it just be who you are and
when you are I mean you are so Liber
ated it it's this massive weight coming
off you it's like yeah kind of up
but you know more than some less than
others but trying and people are like
that's great yeah people are way less
judgy than you think they are right
there's some there's some inverse of it
you know where it's like we think
someone's so but then if we look at the
way we look at people we might have some
jokes about it stuff but most of the
time you have empathy
exact at dinner two nights ago I'm
sitting next this woman and she said
something about was a long story but
basically it was about a woman gaining
weight and I said to her you know I've
never been in a group of just men on a
hunting trip or you know where just men
yeah where someone's like ah she had a
fat ass it's like men have the widest
Strike Zone imaginable men like women
heterosexual men like women they don't
judge their appearance very harshly at
all they kind of tend to like all sorts
of women that's true and if you knew how
non-judgmental men were about women's
appearances you would relax but of
course you don't care what men think
about your appearance you only care what
other women think about your appearance
and they're very judgy but it's the same
principle it's like we are less judged
than we think we are you know yeah it's
funny but you we don't but it's not the
nature of us to think that we are did
you tell people when you quit using
cocaine yeah I did I think let me think
yeah uh yeah I did I told him well I got
got into meetings I didn't it was been
in my family you know my family a lot of
my family uh it's in my family so the
cocaine thing the drug just alcohol
childhood uh issues really a lot of it
is more a lot of my stuff comes from
really intimacy disorders yeah like emo
like uh connectivity disorders um you
know so but then whenever anything
triggers one of those connectivity
disorders uh then my lot of times it
would lead me to doing drugs you know so
um yeah I I I I'm I just love it that
what I love about it is now I get to see
man I saw a dude yesterday who just got
uh a six-month chip you know and the guy
man to see somebody whose life has
changed you get to witness unev it's
unbelievable mirac I totally agree I had
a friend called me this morning right
and we've been friends for years and we
kind of both know know that we have some
of the same problems and uh it was like
the first time he like opened up to him
man and we're both sitting there just
kind of crying on the phone it was just
cuz when he opened up it just made me
kind it just made me feel like I was
like I don't know I just understood him
and it was like I don't know it was just
so important well that's what intimacy
yeah I I've always thought that we
misread intimacy we think it's When
someone tells the truth about other
people it's very easy to tell the truth
about other people it's only when
someone tells the truth about himself
it's only when you admit who you really
are to someone else that you have
intimacy that's the measure of intimacy
if you're willing to tell someone who
you really are you were intimate with
that person and vice versa and that's
totally the key so if you want to know
how many truly close relationships do I
have that's how you know how many people
am I willing to admit what a schmunk I
actually am too that's the number and
what I love about 12ep I've never
actually been to 12ep I've only heard
about it actually went I was at Russell
br's house summer and he had a meeting
yeah oh that's
coolar was it I didn't stay for it I had
to leave but they were one of the guys
was smoking which I love and um just old
school and and they were anyway but but
I love the 12 step thing because you
just like it as with Christianity which
I also like you admit right
away that you are powerless yeah exactly
you're not in control your life's
unmanageable that's a nice word that
they use a lot because it's like
sometimes people like man I'm not
powerless but I'll be like you know
things are unmanageable for me the way
that they phrased everything it was just
really articulate but anyway man well
congrats on that yeah I think it's
interesting and it gives me a better
scope to handle my own life you know and
it definitely gives me more opportunity
to look at other people when I when I'm
able to um do you find yourself less
judgmental and what what about all the
guys you used to do cocaine with do you
still talk I did it by myself good
that's a fun way to do
it shopping outlines at home yeah i'
change outfits and come back in and be a
different guy doing it yeah I'm like hey
don't do any this is for me you know
just yelling at the other
me you're literally doing it alone oh
yeah brother I would do it alone and I'd
go hide it somewhere and I'd be like I'm
going to bed not doing anymore and then
I would get up and go find it
you know and I would do more and it does
affect your sleep
patterns yeah
bro I've heard that yeah most of my
patterns was me praying dude that
somebody would pour Gatorade
down my chimney I was just I want
Gatorade why Gatorade just because it's
like has electrolytes in it I would be
so dehydrated so you're not much of a
planner no no you didn't go to Costco
ahead of time just get a pallet of it
for home no no bro did you have some
pretty crazy nights or no I had a few
yeah p
yeah he going crazy the good news is
that uh I mean it was a different I'm 54
so so a different time in the world that
I started where I started work in
91 everyone went to lunch every day and
I was a writer at a magazine and
everyone went to lunch for an hour and a
half every day period I mean it was a
different economy it was this was before
the corporations took over everything
and imp planted chips on your phone to
listen to your conversation track your
whereabouts and before we became East
Germany they didn't really know where
you were and it was just a civilized
place and you could just have lunch and
and if you drank it was totally within
bounds to have a couple drinks at lunch
you know and smoke at lunch and then
that could keep going I'm not saying it
was great for productivity but it was a
better country that's just a fact it was
yeah it was some fun and um
so I would just say the great blessing
in my life is it definitely erased my
memory of a number of years so I don't
have a lot of guilt simply because I
don't really remember what I was like
but I don't think very appealing yeah
not a great Dr drunk yeah yeah okay and
when you drink like even if you're not
setting out to say use
cocaine you can wind up doing that yeah
yeah oh yeah if somebody's got some
cocaine you're going to stay hang around
them until they don't have it anymore
until you have it I've heard that yeah
that's true oh yeah that's me right
there I did one time I was doing some
cocaine at the house
and uh people like I was like a big vest
guy for about 11 months and
um vest with nothing underneath yeah
this kind the chip andales thing
some shades yeah dude just chilling in
my apartment you dance huh no I wouldn't
dance I'd make a smoothie but um which
is kind of like dancing but just do but
literally nothing underneath it just the
vest yeah no no just the vest yeah cuz I
was this was in California too the W it
was you know weather permitting yeah
it's totally normal people I mean I
remember I grew up in California and I'd
often wear a vest a silk vest kind of
against my nipples I liked it dude
remember when silk came out and it was
like remember silk shirts oh yeah they
were so bad huh I'm not going
to remember yeah I never wore a silk
shirt in my whole life you're a lying I
swear yeah never I never fell for that
good for you actually I fell for it I
never bought anything from Fela oh yeah
and I never did never had anything that
was velour I mean their whole EPO yeah
in fashion history that I just missed I
just totally ignored it I've been
wearing the same freaking clothes since
1984 and I mean it wow I believe that
dude if you just stay exactly the same
like someday this will be super cool for
a moment and then we'll move on to
something else we'll go back to vests
when I was in school it was good man
that was a style yeah yeah you kind of
you seem like you were conceived at like
a Johnson and Murphy and something just
roll right I don't know what
that is but I will take that as a compl
it's like yeah it's a compliment man my
best friend Kevin likes that sh that
store what do Kevin do he does uh I
don't know he's looking for a place
right now but um his wife he got married
but that's Johnson and Murphy they're at
the airport a produc airport I buy
almost no clothes at the
airport but I'm not against it
um so let's get into something important
then right uh did you have
uh I'm just trying to think of where to
take this thing you say trauma no
trouble trouble hooks trouble trauma
Trump those are the those are
buzzword buzzword yep
um make me nervous I'm going to grab
another Zen you mind one in I'm going to
God I almost want to do one but I just
don't know how I'll do with it why don't
we wait until we're about to close cuz
things may happen to you that you're not
ready for okay but it gets wild huh it
gets wild in a subtle way it kind of
grows on you it's not it's not like
doing cocaine okay it's not like firing
up the pipe and yeah you know what I
mean blast off or anything like that
it's a much more subtle organic you just
all of a sudden you feel good yeah then
you feel the power rising from your
central nervous system then sort of
going outward through all the n nerve
endings down to the tips of your fingers
and then up here it just starts
crackling the synapses you just make
connections that you hadn't before I
know I'm making it sound like iasa it's
a lot more subtle than that tuck if you
did like a Tucker a lip Tucker yeah I
would if that was your brand of of
nicotine to do that because I believe in
it tuck Tucka tuck yeah tuck tuck and
you could have a Native American
attached to it I love that I definitely
get picketed but I do it anyway yeah but
some them would love it Native Americans
love dude they certainly do God they
love it and I unlike most people I
actually know some do I yes I do I cuz I
live near I I live near a a population
of Native Americans in Maine in Maine
and employ two and have for years and
they're really wonderful people spent a
lot of time with them and uh they the
two that I know very well both love
tobacco and they have every right to
yeah look I think it let them love it
you know at least leave them with
tobacco you know after everything that
happened to
they gave us tobacco they did 100% wow
yeah it was I mean there are a million
different Native Americans is one of
those terms it's like I'm not not sure
what pasam aquatis have to do with hopes
like it's pretty you know and there was
a lot of beef there was a lot of beef
between native like different Indian
tries oh yeah yeah some of them were
very warlike I think is the term we use
but um no they used a lot of tribes used
it in in uh religious rituals and they
would they would they would use it rect
uhuh really tobacco repositories oo yeah
there's a ram R get it up there oh dang
huh yeah for real look it
up boof and freaking that's insane what
I I can't did Indian yeah let's see
tobacco smoke in them let's see oh there
you go oh yeah look at that okay so that
said it was used by okay imported from
the new
world okay an an insu an insufflation of
tobacco smoke into the rectum by animal
was a medical treatment employed by the
European Physicians right but also it
says um tobacco smoke was used by
Western medal uh as a tool against cold
and drowsiness and drowsiness if
you're if I'm drowsy and you're blowing
smoke in my ass I'm at the I got a wrong
po you definitely do and by the way it's
not even covered now yeah that's crazy
no no that that and leeches are like
completely ignored by the medical
establishment but um yeah it was it was
common the proced was used to treat gut
pain and attempts were often made I'm
not making this up you're factchecking
me in real time no I love this but
applying it by animal was a technique
appropriated from the North American
indigenous people yes that's right wow
see how great is that that's amazing
that they even thought it up I think but
if you're chilling around that long you
got somebody's going to blow smoke in
somebody's
ass you think so yeah yeah dude you get
people around so like how many thousands
of years does it take in The
evolutionary process for someone to say
okay we've reached this point in
Civilization where somebody's got to
blow smoke up someone else's
ass is that before or after the wheel
cuz they never figured out the wheel
look I think it's four years somebody's
blowing smoke at really it's quick I
think it's quick
yeah I mean I don't know it'd be
interesting to see how the first things
happen like that how are the pyramids
built I don't know people talk about it
a lot you know people don't know we
don't know how is that and I'm not by
the way suggesting any Theory yeah no
well look I think but how do we not know
that and why doesn't that make all of us
humble like if we don't know how they
built the pyramids 3 or 4,000 or
actually we don't know when the pyramids
were built to be totally honest yeah if
we don't know that then we don't know
yeah right oh yeah someone should
just say that yeah why don't we just say
we don't know yes yeah all wisdom
begins with acknowledging what you don't
know and anyone who tells you I know the
answer is about to lead you into say war
with Iran or something equally crazy
take the fact you know what I mean like
that's a lie yeah so never trust anybody
who claims to have it all figured out
because he's lying to you well do you
think that one of our polit that one of
the political parties thinks that they
have it all figured out more than the
other I think they both do I mean I
think politicians by their nature are
unwilling by the way every once in a
while you get somebody who shows up and
starts to tell a portion of the truth
and everyone loves him and then he's
always invariably accused of ring
someone at that I got to take him out
you know like Anonymous charges he heed
me in 1985 I can't tell you my name but
it happened they just did this to
Russell Brand yeah there's always
somebody yeah they'll come out with
anybody for yeah but or nobody in his
case I don't think I don't think they
put a name to any of the four people who
are accusing him of sexual assault I'm
not shocked well now there's bot they
can even I mean there's Bots writing
articles now I read an article the other
day about my parents I'd never heard of
either of the two people in the article
are you sure sure yeah it was a bot
article it was a bot have you done 23 in
me I mean are you you're P positive okay
I'm pretty I mean yeah you're right
actually cuz you don't know dude yeah
yeah that's a good point yeah that's a
good point yeah maybe I'm angry at the
wrong woman exactly you know that's a
good point you're telling your shrink
about the wrong
Mom you know I've had frustrating time
buying tickets my brother and I had
tickets one time to a Chicago Bears game
and um someone offered to buy them from
us we were children and I think we were
probably 11 and 13 someone offered to
buy them from us outside of the game and
we said okay we'll sell you our tickets
they were selling offering $25 and we
never had that kind of cash and so we
said okay we'll do it and then they said
they were undercover cops and they were
going to take us to jail and just just
the dumbest group of people we'd ever
met um what I want to talk to you about
is game time you shouldn't have to worry
when you buy tickets to your next big
event game time is the fast and easy way
to buy tickets for all sports music
comedy and Theater events near you some
things I love about the game time app
they have last minute tickets Flash
Deals and views from all seats in the
venue so you know if you're going to if
if there's going to be something in
front of you if there's going to be a
dang um you know pendulum or anything uh
stopping your view take the guess work
out of buying tickets with game time
download the game time app create an
account and use code weekend for $20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem
code
we K ND for $20 off download game time
today last minute tickets low price
guaranteed NBA fans the weight is over
basketball is back and draftking sports
book and official Sports bet partner of
the NBA is celebrating with an
unbeatable offer new customers can score
$200 instantly in bonus bets for
throwing down $5 on the NBA win or lose
it doesn't matter you'll start the
season with an instant dub basketball is
more fun when you're in on the action
download the draftking sports app now
and use code Theo new customers can get
$200 in bonus bets instantly for betting
just $5 only on draftking sports book
with code H EO the crown is yours how
does a free Thanksgiving sound well this
year iata is here to give you cash back
and help make sure your Thanksgiving
table is complete because who wants
turkey without the
gravy turkey is great but we all know
the best part of Thanksgiving dinner is
the
sides starting November 1 for the fourth
year in a row ibata is giving 100% cash
back on your thanks Thanksgiving feast
just add the offers in the app to redeem
for everything you need to make your
Thanksgiving feast complete all you have
to do is shop at your favorite retailers
and upload your receipt ibata gives you
cash back on hundreds of grocery items
from produce to personal care to Pantry
Goods download the ibata app now and use
code Theo to get 100% cash back on your
Thanksgiving dinner starting November
1st just go to the app store or Google
Play Store and download the free iata
app and use code Theo that's IBO TTA in
the Google Play or App Store and use
code Theo yeah I think one of the sad
things these days is
like that we don't know where to get any
information
anymore you know well I I've got one
suggestion um and that is whenever you
not to change a subject I'm just trying
to think no it's a it's a fair question
I mean how do you make sense of the
world if you don't believe what people
are telling you about the world right
how can you make rational decisions if
you if you can't be certain that the
input is is accurate I yeah I I can't
really answer that I I know what I do
which is I don't read any read the New
York Times the Washington I don't want
that in my head you know the Washington
Post or NBC news or they Liars I know
their Liars have written for all three
of those I know that they lie so I don't
get anywhere near it um
when you say they lie does that mean
like you write an article and you give
it to your publisher your
producer um and then they say no and
they change it or what do you no it
means they don't assign stories on
things they want to ignore I see and and
where do they get those orders from it's
all by Instinct you know so their job is
to protect the people who are in charge
you know I mean it's to protect the
people who have power currently the
point of Journalism is to challenge the
people who have power on behalf of the
rest of the country right
um and they've inverted the formula and
so they if you work for the Washington
Post the idea is just protect George you
know Jeff Bezos and his friends at all
cost and that's what they do so but I'll
tell you a way that I I I think it's a
good start to figuring out what's true
is watch what they become hysterical
about you'll see somebody occasionally
say something and people just land on
him shut up shut up let's put him in
jail whatever that guy is saying is true
or it point in the direction of the
truth right when someone says something
that's like legit insane no one's mad at
the schizophrenic on the bus you know
who's talking about whatever the Earth
is flat or lizard people which by the
way may be true I don't even know
playing duck duck goose on a
yeah totally nobody cares because he's
not a threat to anyone because he's
insane yeah insane people are not a
threat to the existing order because
they're crazy they're self-
discrediting but when they become
hysterical about somebody and they're
like he's a conspiracy the without even
refuting what he told you then you know
he's on to something I mean a hurt dog
barks right when you have an infection
someone touches near the infection it
hurts what does that tell you you have
an infection yeah oh I see what you're
saying well do you think that's one of
the reasons why Bobby kenned was looked
that is so crazy 100% yeah and what's so
funny is I said I saw him uh you know
very recently the other night and I said
to him and I saw him I sort of follow it
I'm just interested in the reaction to
Bobby Kennedy and remember they attacked
him as a crazy conspiracy nut cuz the
vaccines and he said there may be a
connection between the vaccines and
autism like shut up and they literally
they canceled his contract with the New
York Times he had a contract to write
for them they canceled it wow and they
just basically drummed him out of plight
Society they don't talk too much about
that anymore right but the vaccine stuff
because I think there is this
recognition and by the way I'm not an
expert but that actually a lot of people
were hurt a lot of people were hurt not
just with the most recent round of
mandatory vacs but in earlier rounds now
you could argue it was worth it you we
have a flu vaccine it academically
supposedly prevents the flu so maybe we
get it and but some people get hurt but
they were telling us for years nobody
gets hurt well that's just a lie yeah
people get hurt all the time with they
get hurt all the time yeah I mean a lot
of vaccines it's like even the polio
vaccine I I I recite this a lot but they
they tested the polio vaccine in our
hometown where I'm from they had a
primate testing facility there and um
are you serious yeah and that's where
they tested the polio vaccine you grew
up in a town with a primate testing
facility yeah what town Tain National
Primate Research
Center that's got to be the most
depressing place in the world is it in
New Orleans it's Uptown it's outside of
New Orleans no no no no this is outside
of New Orleans yeah they don't allow
that in Autobon Park do they all no but
uh in our town this is where they made
it at but that vaccine gave cervical
cancer to tons of women and they knew it
when they put it out but they'd already
ordered it they're like well it we
already paid for it right so exactly but
so that I think that so it's it's bad to
lie and it's especially bad to lie at
scale like if I lie to you about
something and you know yeah but if I'm
lying to 350 million people that's a
that's a crime and they've done it and
the problem is at this point it's like I
mean I I would go to a
surgeon you know CU that's a pretty
straightforward operation I've got a
knife I'm going to take this thing out
or sew this up or whatever but I don't
think I would go to a doctor for well
we're going to try this drug it's like
maybe I would I mean I I don't know
yeah I haven't had to make that choice
thankfully but I would be hesitant
because I don't trust them because they
lied they got caught lying and they
never admitted it that's that that's
part of it there's never any resolution
there's never any affirmation to your
questioning and even if you were right
there's never any about face
acknowledgement it can't get better if
you get in a fight with your girl okay
and one of you behaves horribly MH one
of you is on say cocaine and says
something outrageous and you want to
continue the relationship there has to
come a point where you're like you know
I really was an and I'm sorry
and I love you and I'm sorry I did that
right and only when you do that can it
get better it cannot be healed before
you do that it doesn't work and that's
true with public trust as well and
that's where we've gotten it's gotten to
the point but I don't understand why
they can't admit it like I've been wrong
about a ton of things and I feel so much
better when I admit it and stop
pretending that I'm omniscient I don't
know everything and that's okay why
can't they do that why can't fouchy just
be like wow you know I told you this in
good faith I was wrong and I'm sorry
yeah he would do more for people's trust
in science if he did that he's totally
incapable of that cuz he's a freaking
sociopath dangerous human being he's a
shitty picture too you see that quite a
shitty picture and I say that as a
shitty picture but even I he's got
little dwarf arms but
still sorry no it's okay man look at
this let's show this Bro God get
that dude is out of his he's got
a mask on outside huh dude that guy's
got
but it's so Prima facia it's
like there's a dwarf on the field with a
mask on outside throwing it at the back
boy like this is not a real country if
that guy's running it this is this is a
joke first of all the bat boy's 11 so
he's flirting with a child so let's call
that he's flirting with a child let's
call it what it is freak now half of
America needs a Tommy John surgery in
their heart cuz it is dude myocarditis
right there and there I am with a
slider boy well you don't even
dick around do you is that you I've done
some things but no not on
this where is that that was St
Louis but actually I got to throw one
out for the Diamondbacks that's why I'm
wearing this jersey how nervous were you
um I was pretty nervous I guess it
suddenly makes you feel like how old you
are you're like I'm getting old how
old how old were you I'm 40 oh I was
41 but I'm 43 but I was like oh 43
is pretty old yeah it feels old
sometimes actually does it feel old no
it just feels old when you're you're
running upstairs yeah yeah I know what
I'm talking about I'm I'm 54 yeah I
can't believe that but I always run
upstairs I always run upstairs just
because yeah yeah yeah you're like I'll
show them 100% yeah I've always been and
I'm with my wife who's very fit like
next level fit crazy and she doesn't
even she'll just be prattling on running
upstairs doesn't even she does huh she's
Whimsical I don't know she's Whimsical
she's just got like crazy cardio oh God
cuz she never stopped doing it you know
like when you're a kid they make you do
physical fitness and I took about 40
years off for cigarettes and stuff and
she didn't so yeah it pays off it turns
out who when was your first cigarette do
you remember it yeah I remember it
really well yeah it was delicious and my
father smoked and was very he smoked
unfiltered cigarettes called pel mels he
called them pel mels oh yeah pal malls
but they were extra long flavored with
licorice I think made by the American
Tobacco Company great cigarette in a red
pack
and we had many so that's I don't even
know if there's a picture of the he
smoked right there right there one down
one down that right there that's the
cigarette of my childhood he picked him
up in the Marine Corps when he was 17 I
guess they came in his K ration and that
that was the cigarette in my childhood
there was always one smoldering in an
ashtray in our kitchen and everywhere
else anyway but I was I was like when I
was little I was against it and my
father really loved cigarettes and he
wasn't embarrassed of it it wasn't like
I smoke but I feel bad about it he was
like No And I smoke un filters because
you feel stripping when you're done
there's no filter you smoke them
backwards so the enemy doesn't know it's
an American cigarette you burn the logo
off the off the paper ah he yeah he
really liked cigarettes and he felt
sorry for people who didn't smoke so I
was like maybe 13 I was in e8th grade
when I started and it was it was totally
where were you were you out with the
boys or you was at the house and you
school I was at school smoked one at
school oh yeah it was allow actually it
was a pretty freaky with a teacher I
know it sounds like it was in the 1800s
sounds romantic I think it was romantic
it was great just a sneak it sounds like
Espionage no no no it was totally open
you could smoke at school I could smoke
at school through senior year of high
school oh yeah no oh yeah you could
smoke as a child at school oh yeah I had
parental permission yeah really I
shouldn't be saying this it's you know
what's so funny people would be like
yeah I did I Oscar DMT and everyone's
like it's so cool it's like yeah I
smoked a
cigarette what you're a
criminal um but you know I mean I I
don't I wouldn't I wouldn't say smoking
is a great long-term play yeah I don't
think that it is it where I quit when I
was 45 because I felt like I probably
should yeah it'll probably get me anyway
but I did enjoy it I really did I never
had a bad one you know yeah there are no
bad cigarettes you're not like oh this
is disgusting I never felt that way at
all oh wow yeah I've had bad Fig Newtons
like you can screw up almost any
consumer product but a cigarette is
remarkably
consistent and it gives you what it
promises you the payoff is always there
that's a good point yeah the payoff is
always there you know especially that
first drag off that in the
morning in the morning you know what I
loved was they had a man in our area and
um uh it was actually my grandmother was
uh married to a man and he would light
as cigarette and he would let us inhale
the lit the smoke up our nose when we're
really young Louisiana's the best isn't
it God it was good I think it's
got the highest smoking rate of any
state you know what Louisiana does have
it has the most people that are born
there that die there that never leave
there I believe that it's a cool place
it's not like every other place actually
no dude it is um yeah I always say like
New Orleans it's a good place to get
oysters and murdered yeah you get
murdered and oysters that's totally
right the thing about Louisiana it never
gets credit for everyone talks about
diversity in the Melting Pot like
Louisiana actually was that long before
most places yeah it was you had a bunch
of different cultures there and they
kind of got along you know sort of
anyway yeah you still got a good mix
down there yeah we had a uh area bu us
called chauna that was the river and it
was named after the chauna Indians
chauna is that like the fagawi tribe um
I'm not sure that's not a real that
cannot be a real name it's a real name
TC EF um funa yep yeah CH it does sound
like river right there in
Louisiana yeah it sounds like a play on
words yeah it does well here's how they
got the name a long time ago a Native
American uh threw a big rock into the
river and that's the sound when it made
when it went in ch oh that's so cool is
that true yeah true story it's pretty
fascinating but that right there is a
perfect example Louisiana to me is that
it's a place for great storytelling it's
a great place for kind of uh U Family Y
you know so that's one story I like to
tell about have dinners with their
families there people have 90-minute
lunch breaks people wake up get to
breakfast and then do two or three
things before they go to lunch I love
that yeah it was part it was just that's
how life was it was it wasn't all about
efficiency no it wasn't so if your life
is all about efficiency and every moment
is being monitored and counts towards
something then you're not really human
you're a machine at that point aren't
you I mean you're a or a cog in a larger
machine and that's what I think a lot of
people feel like these days well and for
good reason there's some chick on the
internet like 22-year-old experiencing
life in the corporate world for the
first time and she does this video like
this is terrible I don't make any money
and they treat me like and treat me
like you know I'm not worth anything I'm
not human and everyone's like shut up
and work honey yeah and I watch this and
I'm like no no I hope you win I hope you
win I hope you I I
oh like I I the seeds of Revolution are
sprouting in my heart I just so hate
that culture oh yeah it treats people
like they're not people like for what
yeah well I mean I think for some people
in my own sense learning to be a boss
and leader has been tough just because I
never I you know I just started out
wanting to be a comedian I wanted to
sleep in of course and master baate and
go a lot right be chatty no I didn't get
crazy with it okay I didn't like yeah I
was kind of compulsive or anything like
no no I was an organized efficient M
yeah just good okay that's fair yeah
one-off kind of guy yeah kind of like
when they play the trumpet in the
morning you never got greedy though you
never went back never I got greedy yeah
I was like that's it yeah but um so I
think learning to do that personally has
been a little it's been a journey for me
but yeah I think with with with
companies it's like how do we get away
from that and is it just sometimes I
think America was just this Christian
experiment yes that got compromised and
has turned out poorly you think yes I
think you're on to something there and I
hate to say that because the part of me
doesn't really want to admit it well
it's obviously true it's obviously true
I mean you can't have a democracy unless
it's a voluntary system people have to
show a lot of restraint they have to be
Allin there has to be some sense of the
common good you can't just be like how
much can I grab it's like Halloween it
doesn't work if all the kids just empty
the basket on the front steps you know
in the first wave of trick-or-treaters
no it's true though no you're right and
and a democracy is very much the same
way cuz you can take power and then just
like steal everybody's money legally and
so you really have to have some
boundaries that you impose on yourself
and if and and that has to come from
within you have to have the sense that
someone more powerful like I hate to use
the word but God is watching and if you
don't have that then it just descends
into greed and selfishness which is
where we are now have have we let
because it's do you think America is
still a Christian Nation no no what is
it um it's an LLC as you said so
brilliantly actually again we've
privatized communism it feels like to me
that's exactly right I mean I don't no
one's for the free market everyone's for
using power to hobble their competitors
you know everyone's into the only reason
we have regulations is to create
monopolies um the system is completely
rigged and you know that you're asking
how do you get reliable information
about the news the news media want to
talk about race that's like their main
thing that they want to talk about black
white hispanic Asian but that's actually
not an interesting conversation because
you can't change your race and like
people are different races and they're
sort of different but they're also very
much the same it's like not that
interesting a topic to me personally I'm
not interested in talking about race
what's really interesting is that the
United States of America is being looted
by a small number of people who are
getting away with it and they don't want
to talk about that they never want to
talk about economics they never want to
talk about the tax code they never want
to talk about any of that stuff ever and
that's how you know that CNBC and CNN
and the New York Times and all these
people are like looking out for you are
actually just petorian guard standing in
front of the people with the most power
and money and keeping the masses from
asking uncomfortable questions and so
whenever anyone asks about like well
wait a second you know why do we tax
people at half the rate for investing
that we do for working literally they
pay half the tax rate so you have a job
and you work every day and like and you
pay pay one rate but if you just stay
home and invest money and live off the
interest you pay half as much so are we
saying it's twice as virtuous to invest
as it is to work oh is that what we're
saying so if you're a day trader or just
trading stocks or something you don't
have to pay or if you're private Equity
guy and you can claim that your income
is actually
investment is interest on your
Investments you pay half the taxes so we
have a we have a tax code that
discourages
work and encourages parasitic Behavior
now there are arguments on both sides
and I'm not an economist but you don't
even hear those arguments because it's
like shut up racism yeah tranes or
whatever it's all a distraction from
what the real story is which is they're
looting the country looting and at this
point you know we can't repay the debt
that we owe so it's going to be like
well unfortunately we had to sell
Yellowstone yeah and no I mean it's
going to get to the point where we're we
sold it to Asians you no for real where
we're I mean what is and then they're
going to say the sale was racist too
that's going to be the craziest part
you're asking questions about it is
racist okay yeah you're always the RAC
just to be clear you're always the
racist Louisiana man he wasn't David
Duke from Louisiana shut up clansmen D I
used to lift weights with David Duke oh
God in prison no I can see you guys in
the yard AR all the ARA Nation guys he's
like on your back cuz you're doing
push-ups bro I was never in any Aran
Nation dude you know not even in prison
no I never even went to any of their
meetings or anything I saw pamphlets or
whatever but I never pulled up over
there um but yeah we shared our back
fence and I he used to date this hot
girl that worked at a seafood restaurant
that I worked at and so he'd pop in
there and I'd watch him meat shrimp or
whatever but what was the seafood
restaurant it was called Morton's
Seafood in Madisonville right on the
Chun the river really worked over there
baby and I was a bus boy and they used
to have raccoons coming out the wall
when they'd cook duck the boarding was
bad on the wall it had rotted out and
they let one of bus boys get there with
a uh with a broomstick we'd have to
stand there and beat the raccoons back
in the wall they're ferocious animals
well they love duck of course they do
and pizza oh really oh yeah oh wow they
call them trash pandas where I live and
you see them outside in the trash cans
oh yeah and they love pizza I like pizza
oh yeah unfortunately and oh yeah you
have pizza and you you know yeah they go
crazy I'd love to see now that that
would be a good Dave pory thing where he
gives a he does one bite to a hit a
with a bite you know what have you ever
seen a raccoon eat you never gave them
any duck did you oh I pulled up on them
and they're always like this we right
with their hands we didn't do it they
totally the gayest one is the one in the
recycling Ben he's always like wait you
know at least the other ones are in the
trash there's always that one that kind
of wanders up the recycling bin and he's
wearing like a negl your mom's or
something you're like what the has
that one been doing you know but yeah
they always are like plead innocent or
whatever I know they do they're so
clever I love them oh they're crafty
yeah I've never shot one I've seen him
so many times in the woods there they
are yeah they love dog food yeah that's
that's kind of a mangy one I've seen we
have big ones where I live yeah I grew
up around a lot of Rayes so when woman
would come down the street we'd all have
to go inside do a lot of people of
rabies where you grew up yeah I would
say it was there was a big scare of it
when was rabies popular can you look
that up
please when was rabies popular when I
was a kid it was a big thing get out the
street you know there's a sick raccoon
or and and um but when they got cars and
electricity and stuff they fixed all
that I mean they just it wasn't as big
of a thing but um but yeah David Duke
man we go to the gym sometimes and I'll
say this nice guy yeah I never met him
nice guy you know he never you know we
just did chest and tries or whatever
there was never any racial things or
whatever you know but he was a very fit
man I've never met him but I will say
this and I'm not saying he's a Fed
though he's obviously a Fed but every
time I would get a new show
I don't know anything about David Duke
I'm from La Hoya California he wasn't
quite as popular there yeah can we find
another picture
[Music]
without but every time I get a new show
there would be some news story David
Duke endorses Tucker
girls be like why you I don't know you I
don't know anything about you I'm from
La Hoya okay we don't share a common
culture yeah I'm from Mitt Romney
country 100% literally Mitt Romney goes
to La Comedy Store IED Comedy Store La
Hoya is one of my favorite be my
favorite comedy club in the whole
country been there a long time since I
was a child really up in the village
yeah yeah in fact there was a Jack In
The Box next door that I used to ride my
bike to um I remember that jack it
wasn't it it was maybe disappeared a few
years ago if it did or they Clos it down
for a while cuz they got caught selling
kangaroom meat oh yeah in the 70s and I
don't I don't know if that story was
actually true but that's what everyone
in the town thought I mean look if you
can get a couple grams of Rue in
La Hoy rub Burgers that's what we called
them that's so
took a close look at the meat it was
gray and kind of gristly and it was not
beef I mean I and I think the company
was owned by ralon Purina at one point
oh yeah and they're out of um I believe
they're out of oh are they I think yeah
I know they're out of the Midwest um but
yeah I loved it over there you would
always hear I I love La Hoya it's a
beautiful area um but they weren't big
on racism there when I was a kid yeah I
don't know yeah I don't know if they
well it's mostly white there well that's
why they're not picking racism right
like yeah people are expecting we can't
do it no it was like rich white people
oh yeah Rich white people oh yeah know
it seemed like rich people yeah for sure
yeah it's like yeah you feel rich even
when you're driving by or you feel like
people want you to leave I feel like it
was it's beautiful there yeah it's
really pretty it's very beautiful sad
though soulless is it yes yeah no soul
at all no one had a last name I mean it
was obviously it's one of the prettiest
places in the world but yeah it was you
know hi I'm Bob I'm a Sagittarius like
nobody had a real connection to anyone
else everyone was just kind of passing
through and it the first time I went to
New Orleans which is obviously a
disgusting place but I loved it because
it was so it was just so thick it was
just so much there and all these weird
rituals and customs and just had a
culture and I just didn't grow up around
that at all and even though I didn't
understand what they were doing in New
Orleans and obviously I was very
threatened by it
because like half the town is a violent
criminal right but I still liked it
because I thought this is interesting in
a way that nothing I grew up with was
interesting at all I could totally see
that yeah I think I grew up in a place
that was just so you know it was just
there was so much lore and stuff in our
area that um and I think that's just a
lot of the way that Louisiana was Amos
Moses this from Louisiana I don't know
but I love that song but you just
picture you know wrestling alligators in
the swamp and where I grew up people
literally talked about the weather every
single day every day and the weather
never changed it wasn't like we lived in
Minnesota or something it's very Truman
Show there in L it's unbelievable be
like well it's it's going to be 72 and
partly cloudy moving to mostly sunny in
the afternoon it's going to be 68
overnight tomorrow it's and it would
just be on an endless repeat it was a
skipping record did you hate that about
yourself that like like was there any
self like Lo cuz like I hated myself
because I was poor right but does that
happen on the other end of the spectrum
or and I hated my neighborhood I just
felt embar embarrassed right like um
does that happen on the other end of the
spectrum where people no not enough
there should be a lot more self-hatred
in rich neighborhoods I think and I hate
to say self-hatred sorry I was ashamed
of myself that's a better way to say
there should be more shame it should be
more shame like if you've amassed a100
million from sucking the last remaining
lifeblood out of some Manufacturing
Company in the midwest yeah calling it
private Equity like you should hate
yourself a little bit you know what I
mean and there's none of that and I
think that that's part of the problem
there's not enough guilt among the
ruling class there's no sense of
obligation to people beneath them and
that's one of the reasons they hate them
so much and that's one of the reasons
that the fentel crisis has not even been
acknowledged by Washington is because
they kind of know they're responsible
for it and you wind up hating the people
you've wronged I have noticed like what
do you mean that you might wind up
hating if you commit a sin against
somebody if you're cruel to somebody
unfair to somebody you cheat somebody
you wind up hating that person as a way
of justifying what you you did and the
only way to stop that is by admitting
what you did and saying it out loud to
the person's face and asking for his
forgiveness which again is why 12ep
model works right but if you don't do
that you wind up blaming the person for
the crime that you committed against him
and that's one of the reasons that
people who don't get sober are so angry
at the world they're pissed at their
parents you meet these people their
parents send them to rehab six times and
they're pissed at their parents yeah why
are you mad at your parents they did
everything they could and the reason
that junkie's mad at his parents is
because he knows that he's actually the
guilty party and he's committed massive
crimes against them but he can't admit
it so he blames them and that is true at
a macro level as well and if your ruling
class of all the richest people have
gotten Rich by over the people
beneath them running these fascist
companies that spy on their employees
phone calls and like track them as they
come in and out of the building and
require them to work on Sundays with no
overtime and just really inhumane sweat
shop type practices creepy stsy stuff
those people end up having great
contempt for their own employees do do
you know what I mean yeah well I think
it's one of the spaces we're getting to
right now in the country is people if
you're an owner of something if you are
a well you know what's interesting is
when you say that I me recently met a
guy who was a Democrat right he's like a
devout Democrat right and he said to me
this was interesting I never heard this
he said you know I vote for Democrats
because I want their to be programs in
place to keep the people
that are struggling I want to keep them
at I want to satiate them just enough so
they don't Rebel they don't have power
right and I never heard that I that out
loud yeah he said that to me and I was
like that's so i' never heard that here
your we weed here's your porn just don't
make a mess just don't make a mess so
that the rest of us who don't who aren't
as unfortunate as you can still operate
like we operate okay so it blew my I
just never heard that perspective was
this on camera that the person no this
was just in a human conversation as two
humans eating uh an inhuman conversation
really in what yeah I had a salad I
don't know what he had we were having
lunch he the blood of children probably
I would say sounds that way he had a O
Negative yeah Junior yeah I mean that is
so dark but it's so true and and by the
way bless him for his honesty because
that is exactly what's going on
that's not how you treat your own KS or
people you you'd never say I'm going to
keep you on just enough assistance that
you canot starve to death but that
you'll be like so harried by the
shittiness of your existence that you'll
never challenge my power like that is a
crime committ against that well that's
that's to me as an as an American value
that was like oh that's never a way that
I ever would thought or think no cuz you
encourage self-sufficiency cuz that's
where self-respect comes from I've got
my in a pile and I'm proud of
myself that's the goal for an adult man
and if you're preventing people from
getting to that then you are committing
a crime and you should be held
accountable for it in my opinion but
there's nobody to hold anybody
accountable anymore it feels that I know
well I'm very aware of that everyone's
in on it well it's just so interesting
how do we get out of it then by saying
the truth out loud I think that's the
only recourse I think that's more
powerful than than guns I mean I do
saying trth I mean that's what they get
hysterical about be
and'll be days we need to take our guns
away they not going take your guns they
but that's not their priority but when
somebody says something that's true I
mean they will disappear a person for
that like you'll never hear from them
again and there's a reason and the
reason is nothing is a greater threat to
the people running things than true
words and that's why Kanye you mean I'm
not talking about well Kanye was
disappeared yeah I mean and my view of
Kanye would be
you know if if you show up on Alex Jones
in a hockey mask saying you love Hitler
you're probably not really a threat to
anybody I mean really a lot of people
are going to watch Kanye being like I
love Hitler and be like wow I love
Hitler too yeah no no no oh you might be
able to walk on with the Devil Rays
maybe you know no no but I'm just saying
like that wasn't if if you actually
wanted to promote Hitler and I hope no
one would ever want to promote Hitler
but like if you did that would not be
the way to do it right so actually how
is Kanye a threat to anybody I don't
think he was he is yeah and by the way
he's a he's a recording artist he's a
musician so like and a clothing designer
he's not in charge of federal policy so
I did think yeah I thought that was
distressing just because I don't think
anybody should be silenced if you're not
committing violence against somebody you
have the right as a human being because
you are not a slave You Are a Human
Being you have the right to say what you
think that is that is a foundation right
and if you don't have the right to say
what you think then you're not a human
being you're a slave like that's the
assd test am I a slave or not I don't
know one simple question can you say
what you really think and if you can't
then you're a slave super simple well
now it feels like they own it used to
feel like you could write what you think
but they now it feels like the paper is
owned right yeah so they can like even
with AI coming out it's like they could
even adjust what you write so you don't
even have a value to write
anything anymore it's like hey just put
in kind of how you feel will write what
you what you're saying like it's getting
to that you know what I'm saying it
almost starts to it could be two years
from that where it's
like I've been a writer all my life and
to see now
machines doing that and actually doing a
fairly you know serviceable job I mean
writing poetry and screenplays and like
yeah giving me a fake
father you what but upgrade or no uh a
little younger than my dad but I don't
know that guy seemed a little bit deep
my father seem a little happier than him
um fair I'm going to urinate real fast
you're going to urinate yeah that right
like a racehorse my brother you ever
owned a horse never owned a horse I'm a
dog guy really you ever bet on dogs you
ever put one in at the
track honestly yes I have yeah in
Florida and in fact in Florida in the
80s and that dog track has now been
closed and I love dogs and I've always
loved dogs and it's the one in Miami
that's near the airp and it was the most
depressing inhumane like you just wanted
to send money to pea spending 20 minutes
there but I did go there yes I had been
drinking and probably other things and I
did bet on the Greyhounds and I feel bad
about it yeah I do you ever ridden on
Greyhound I've always I've always been a
sizable man I could and they Buck me off
every time I try really yeah wheel
around and bite me yeah they they don't
it's hard to saddle a greyhound no I
mean the bus service oh sorry sorry I
thought you meant the dogs oh no oh I
spent a lot of time on actually true
story yeah I had a girlfriend in high
school um but we went to different
colleges and she went to Vanderbilt
University in Nashville Tennessee and I
I live to New England which is a small
colder region shout out will Shepard
over there go on and I took the bus I
took a Greyhound bus from Washington DC
where my parents lived to Nashville
which is like 12 hours yeah and then I
took one back and so this bus was going
on to New York City and for some reason
it was 100% Puerto Rican and me and I
was at the back of the bus and it left
like midnight yeah and I was drinking
and smoking on the that's how long ago
it was this was 1987 I'll never forget
it and I fall asleep cuz I'm so loaded
I'm taking a leak in the empty cans you
know just doing what you doing life dude
and all of a sudden I feel this wet
grainy thing on my face and these people
right there in the seat right across the
aisle were just just like full cus just
like oh yeah playing couch ball just
full-blown a six sound effects
everything and the guy was wearing
socks and one of the socks hit my face
and it was just moist and it had a lot
of gravel from the ground on it and I
remember thinking this is the I can't
wait to get off this bus yeah it was
dark it was nothing erotic about it at
all oh yeah right I mean I don't know it
depends on what you're you know how you
were at the time I think well I was
drunk and in a dead sleep and they're
rolling around and she's making these
animal noises like they were not at all
inhibited which was kind of impressive
in a way but I felt it was very much an
intrusion into my space wow yeah that's
fair like hey is there any zoning over
here right what yeah who yeah do we have
a town plan that's a true that's a true
story yeah oh that's good oh Greyhound's
unbelievable dude arm remember one time
a guy's on there right sitting by me he
goes hey uh and yeah there was a brother
on there and he goes hey want to see
something and I thought it was going to
be um his wiener right cuz I've been on
the bus before and but you said yes well
it was a two-hour ride I was like I'll
see it now you know I'm not
going to pretend she thought he cut a
hole in the bottom of the back yeah I
thought I get it I get it some weener
trick there totally the old Greyhound
Wier
[Laughter]
trick and uh I was like yeah I'll see it
you know and uh he had a bag of jewelry
and a gun and he just robbed a jewelry
store wow had a bag gun no I didn't buy
any but he wanted me to sit there and
look at it and I put on a couple of the
necklaces or whatever and um did you act
impressed oh yeah cuz I was scared and
they always give the guy you know once
you if you get out of jail they give you
a ticket on the Greyhound
imagine you rob a jewelry store and your
getaway vehicle is a Greyhound bus
unbelievable you are if you're
doing that you're like we got to get out
of here in seven hours here I bought the
ticket yeah it's pretty cool dude it was
a yeah I mean I loved riding Greyhound I
used to work on a farm up in uh
Mississippi and so I would take a
Greyhound bus up there and um and I
would ride it up there and there was
always people on there there the
bathroom like on it was always closed
they said you know um I was on one where
yeah part of it was on fire I was on one
where a guy stopped to meet his
ex or something for like 20 minutes and
we all had a chill at a
IHOP no way 100% dude go to Greyhound
bus Twitter feed Greyhound bus help and
look at their replies on there bro
welcome to America bro I love that so
it's just like every Waffle House they
stop at oh it's just like uh the bus
supposed to leave at 4:30 it's 970
somebody like it's
970 well you have a bad watch but like
it's 972 people are pregnant it's just
the list goes on man chances I'd like
the people on those buses
100% everything on here is
unbelievable this is but seriously all
drivers allow my bag to be stol on this
trip where's customer service yeah go
back one they got a video let me see
that video on there I this is what I do
at night I go to Greyhound bus help
Twitter feed and they'll show stuff yeah
little eight balls between the seats or
different things there's somebody found
a gram down there between the seats did
you ever do that uh I never found any
drugs on there oh that might be somebody
touching themselves don't let that video
finish
please but I spent a lot of time on this
man it's insane though Greyhound bus
hell it's called Greyhound bus help but
yeah they could change it it would still
work um I'm G to urinate real fast all
right so sorry I had to urinate and
that's why I I heard it yeah well then
it's okay strong stream saddest part was
being little and just not being able to
pee in there
and I grew up around we had a lot of
dudes and they would hold a lot of
brothers back three or four years so
you'd have a big brother in there and
he'd pee with his dude Mr Larry right Mr
Larry yeah he was like they'd held him
back like seven times right so at that
point you got to respect him you know
100% And he would urinate over your back
and it just just right into the urinal
dude you'd be standing there peeing
right you're like this scared kid
remember how scary it was your first
time you had to go into the urinals as a
kid no oh well I grew up in a less
strengthening envir
there was no one doing piss rainbows
over my shoulder
no he was the Gary Payton to
pissie he would shoot from deep
and so you'd literally be peeing imagine
this and you can't pee you're scared and
then a pee comes just from above
and goes perfectly in that's so
impressive he feel demoralized though no
but I mean the pounds per square in just
the the
velocity you you know what I mean you'd
think you'd almost need CO2
to get that much
power yeah it was impressive man it's
crazy what some men can do you know or
young men or ad you know adolescence
yeah there's not a lot of dribbling at
that AG yeah oh there wasn't any
dribbling dude no dribbling it's like at
the end it's like Bam off it's like the
Bellagio Fountains like when it's done
it's done I do respect that um what uh
so what's your how what is news like
around the world that's something I
don't understand so different it's crazy
you you don't
realize that we live in this bizarre
biosphere where you have no idea what's
going on in the rest of the world you
have no idea how you're perceived the
United States is perceived and you have
no idea really you're place in the
global order because we're cut off from
the rest of the world and we have these
two extremely lame irrelevant countries
bordering us but that's it you know
Mexico and Canada no offense I like them
both but like nobody cares but there are
big important countries around the world
and they're very focused on the United
States they have all these views about
what we're doing and those views are
never expressed here so if you're a
leader in the United States you going be
like well we're doing this for democracy
this is the arsenal of democracy and
then you go to the countries that are
directly affected by those policies and
they're like you're freaking insane you
have no idea what you're talking about I
mean the mindblower for me this summer
we traveled all over the world bunch of
different continents and we're still
doing it because I got fired so I I've
been stuck in a studio for all those
years now you got to get out and about
well kind of I mean I go on vacation for
two weeks a year but that was it you
know when you do well you do a show
regularly it's you're tied to where you
are period you're in a studio yeah so
all of a sudden I'm like wow I'm kind of
emancipated yeah for a few months and it
was a summertime and anyway so we went
but the shock for me was and this is not
a partisan point at all at all and what
does partisan mean it means like
carrying water for a party like this is
what Republicans think or this is what
Democrats think so nonpartisan means not
this is just right is true like it
doesn't matter what the either party
says okay what does nonpartisan mean it
just means not partisan it's not you're
not connected to a party you're not
helping either party okay but what I
mean is both parties Republican and
Democrat were saying for a year and a
half Ukraine is winning this war against
Russia yeah I remember hearing that oh
yeah I mean and I still think people
believe that so whatever you think of
the war Russia Ukraine I mean you know
I'm not that interested honestly CU I'm
not Russian or Ukrainian is the truth
but lots of Americans seem to be
interested they have their little
Ukrainian flags and they're you know
learning to pronounce Kev as keev and
they're doing all the steps that you
need to do repeating all the dumb
slogans Slava Ukraine yeah they don't
you know whatever Americans have this
thing where they have no idea where
something is but they're like all of a
I'm you see it now with the Middle East
I'm an expert you know it's like the
Noba what yeah stop but anyway but the
Article of Faith for most Americans was
that Ukraine is winning this war so I
mean I don't how do I know you know what
I mean I'm stuck in a studio so I go
over to the region to two different
countries at Board of Ukraine oh you
popped over there to Ukraine no no I
didn't go to Ukraine no I don't think I
do well in Ukraine no they really well
the government in Ukraine has like
attacked me by name a lot so I I feel
like that was unwise who's their Master
over there their
leader uh well the president is a guy
called Vladimir zinski oh right that's
right he's a comedian yeah a
very unfunny one um yeah do we have any
videos of him doing stand-up
comedy he's he's got one where he's
playing the piano with his dick I know
if you can find that oh really yeah but
yeah and actually fairly well was it at
a Sig app house where was that it was in
Ukraine somewhere I think that's yeah
it's a pretty common
thing um there oh there he is playing
piano with his penis yes is he
really oh
yes oh anybody can be president now well
I don't know can you play the piano with
your penis huh I know
little bit of Boven
that's kind of hacky but it's cute
though that was good I like that I said
that just I because I you might I love
that I wish ID said that but anyway so
whatever I I don't care about these guys
in any way but I I go over there and I
start talking to very knowledgeable
people like the people who run these
countries and they're like what no
Russia has a 100 million more people
than Ukraine 100 million wow and much
deeper industrial capacity they have all
these weapons factories like you're not
going to it's the largest country in the
world by land mass you're there's no
literally no chance even theoretically
Ukraine could beat them but aren't they
an industrial old aren't they Fu aren't
they you know things made out of stone
aren't they like living in the past with
a lot of like techn like well it turns
out I mean military Advanced well we
always made fun of it you know during
the Soviet period because it was super
inefficient and they were all drunk and
they would crash their commercial
airliners all the time from drunkenness
all the time yeah in fact a famous their
PL their carrier the international
carrier their National carrier is called
aeroflot Russian carrier was the Soviet
carrier and in a very very famous crash
the pilot had his son in the cockpit
with passengers on the plane and the
cockpit voice recorder proved this and
the sun just takes the
Yoke just pushes it down and flies the
plane right into the ground so like
people made fun correctly of Soviet
technology but it turns out they were
actually pretty good at this you know
they produced a lot of chess players
they're not stupid people at all and Ne
they the ukrainians for that matter but
anyway the point is the Russians were
never going to lose period and anyone
who looked at it objectively would know
that except no one in the United States
knew that so that kind of freak me out
I'm like we have a big country Smart
Country very the most advanced country
in the world supposedly and nobody even
knows a basic fact really wi like Russia
has a 100 million more people of course
they're not going to lose to Ukraine
like that's insane and yet nobody knew
that so I thought wow what else don't we
know yeah you know and like the amount
of lying that you can do in a world
where everything is controlled all
information is controlled with the
exception pretty much of
Twitter because the guy who owns it is
said he's not going to sensor yeah El
it's nice I feel like that's one thing
that I thought was that yeah maybe
that's it that's what's about censorship
is at least you feel like you
can say things uh or that things can be
shared on there because didn't do you
feel I mean as someone who writes comedy
who does this every day do you feel
Freer on the platform now on Twitter
yeah I feel like at least if YouTube
takes me down oh look at that comedy is
legal on this platform so Elon like
specifically endorsed your right to say
yeah it was nice of we had Roseanne Bar
on and she's a I like her a lot oh dude
she did so much for comedy she
did so much for women and gay days and
uh oh wait I saw part of that and they
uh Hollywood threw under the bus
as soon as they had a chance because
they're heartless and um and so anyway
she was on my show and she I saw that
and they took tell me if I'm
misremembering this they took a line
that she had and they cut out all the
context and put it like on Tik Tok and
it made her sound like she was a crazy
person or a vicious person which she's
not either one of yeah she's a Jewish I
mean she was born Jewish I think she's
still Jewish right she is and so she
said um yeah oh and the Holocaust never
happened right she said sarcastically
right of I think she had relatives who
died in it
yes very obvious right right of course
and they some guy on Twitter assle Sam I
don't know what the guy's name was
something fuckl Stein or somebody he
made a big deal about it from
the Minneapolis fuckle Steins yeah
probably I know them this dude this this
was two weeks after right makes a big
deal about or just put that clip and or
whatever no context so then YouTube took
us down took that episode down but we
got to put it on Twitter so that was
nice at least because it was an honest
place you know um but what I worry about
is like didn't some of these companies
didn't Twitter or Facebook didn't they
get in trouble for not letting like
during election times like not real
information being allowed to be shared
yeah I mean I don't know who would get
them in trouble they run everything and
and you know my concern would be as
we're getting to this election it's very
intense you know I think they're you
know very intense people on both sides
and um if you actually had a platform
that was open for everyone to say what
he or she thinks that's a massive threat
to the community and I think
that the because the truth is always a
threat to Liars that's just that never
changes people are killed never for
lying ever they're only killed for
telling the truth you're only punished
for telling the truth people get mad
it's because you told the truth everyone
should know that so I mean I don't I
can't imagine the pressure that's going
to come to bear on this company X now
over the next year I mean it you know
it's going to be without precedent I
think do you think Elon could be I mean
there could be like even an
assassination attempt on him or
something I would never speculate about
something like that but I just think
there's you can't you're a guy a bar
what are you going to say you know you
know I I I think there's going to be I
would have a food taster I mean I think
it's I think look the one the one thing
we look if you're doing a great job at
something if you're a great father great
husband great employer great comedian
you're not too worried because you know
you're doing a good job but if you're
doing a bad job and the only beneficiary
of your work is you and everyone else is
getting screwed and they can't even
afford to fill up their truck or buy
groceries and you're still getting rich
you're very worried dictators are always
worried about their own security okay so
what's the biggest threat to you the
biggest threat is someone calling you
out and so you have to shut down any
medium where that could possibly happen
so obviously Facebook is completely
controlled Google is completely
controlled Tik Tok foreign on company
God knows what their agenda is so really
the only big platform that's pretty not
controlled with some apparently some
limits but in general it's not
controlled it's free speech is X I agree
so like there's a lot at stake
legitimate leaders don't worry about
this if if I'm a legitimate leader if
I'm a good father and one of my kids is
like I want to smoke weed at The
Breakfast Table you're like you can't
sorry cuz I make the rules no weed at
The Breakfast Table I'm not worried
about saying that because I think I'm a
pretty good father and I think my kids
think I'm a pretty good father but if
I'm a terrible father who's abusing my
kids I can't let them say anything
because the authorities might find out I
I could get punished for what they know
and that is the same attitude that every
dictator has that's why all dictators
take the guns and impose censorship is
the first thing they do m they don't
want to throw you in prison it's
expensive it's difficult they don't want
to execute you they just want you to
shut up and be obedient and Elon Musk in
buying this platform and opening it up
to all positions even unpopular ones is
the single greatest threat to their
hegemony to their control and uh you
know I'm not predicting their response
but I mean it's going to be intense
super intense I can say that do you have
security and a that sort of thing if you
were him would you have like somebody
you know would you make sure that the
Tesla truck which is supposed to been
out for 17 years but that it has extra
bulletproof in the glass I would
definitely include as a standard feature
not an add-on the oil tanks that drop
the oil onto the road behind you so the
people pursuing you spin out and like go
right into a bridge of butman or off the
side of the mountain off M Holland you
know what I mean I would definitely do
that and I'd have like hidden machine
guns under the side view mirrors I'd
have a death ray possibly that would
probably be a custom feature but I would
I would have stuff like that yeah for
sure do you think we get Fair news about
like even the war like in is in uh
Israel and Hamas like do you think we
get Fair information about that like Joe
Rogan had a lady on recently and she was
saying that like the perception of what
happens over there isn't the information
that we get you know did you see that
think of it this way what's at stake
people's lives control of governments
control of
land you know ancient rivalries and
hatreds I mean there's so much at stake
here is the Celtics in the Lakers from
the Bible that of course yeah I mean
it's very intense and so of course
there's going to be massive lying on all
sides and there is and and that's fine
and you go into it knowing that I've
spent a lot of time over there and I
will freely confess I don't understand a
lot of the Dynamics because I'm from La
Hoya I'm not from you know Janine or
Jerusalem or Cutter it's like I'm not
from the region okay I don't speak the
languages but I know enough to know that
there's massive lying and and I think
it's good to know that the only thing
that enrages me is when you hear people
say you know you must believe me I have
no obligation to believe anybody you
have an obligation if you want me to
believe you to prove what you're saying
right and I have a right to ask simple
fair questions how do you know that how
can I trust that how and if and if you
don't give me those answers then I just
don't believe you and I don't have to
believe you and if your recourse is
you're a bad person for not believing me
you that's my response you and
especially in this case where my money
and potentially my children's lives well
that was a cocaine thing you just did
yeah one of these things got blown out
of my nose so every now and then I got
to make sure it works you got to open it
upes I agree with that respect just
widen them out there's no shame God it
didn't it feel good doesn't it god dude
if I can feel it dripping down the back
of my throat right now anyway sorry to
use profanity on your show but it
somebody put on some Casa you know let's
rock is that what you listen to
I don't know what happened dude what
were you listening to I think it was
probably yeah some Casa some traveling
will berries traveling willber maybe a
little bit of a the soundtrack of your
private cocaine use the
travel I got a unique list you know a
little maybe some Morgan W different you
know eclectic mix I think James Blake
maybe what about Dustin a baggie but
Billy strings I've never heard that I
love Billy strings but I haven't heard
DUS in a baggy oh it's a great tune and
it's about dust and a baggie I thought
it was an Irish guy Dustin the
bagy that's good met him that's good
Dustin hey Dustin mom's
pissed sorry I'm just have youever been
to Boston I've been to Pittsburgh though
Dave Chappelle was just in Boston man
you saw what they did to him over there
it unbelievable yeah do you think that's
fair that they should cuz well it's not
fair but it's like I don't know if you
go to listen to Dave Chappelle these
days you know he's going to talk more
about a lot of stuff you know Dave
Chappelle criticizes Israel fars with
crowd at Boston show oh he criticized
Israel so I didn't know that's exactly
what he did I mean look I wasn't there I
only know what I read I wasn't there
either I think da he made one point
which I think is entirely I don't know
if I agree I I don't agree with Dave
trelle on everything of course um but
the one point that I read that I did
agree with was the United States is
implicated in this and so we have a
right to have an opinion on it and that
is obviously true and anyone who tells
you you don't have a right to have an
opinion or you must have one specific
opinion yeah um is wrong and I think
it's fair to say that yeah yeah I think
people should be able to have their um
their opinions you know yeah because
once you don't have your opinion
then it's like how do you how do you get
to a revolution how do we get to a
revolution because at what point do
people just say well if my life doesn't
if you don't want my life to mean
anything to me based on how you've set
up the environment at what point do you
go from there to then I
am not GNA play this game or how does a
Revolution start right they're very
worried about it that's why they're
putting people in prison um and I think
they should be worried about it they are
worried I'd love to be on a
horse back dude well but you know how
you get your Revolution Is by not
listening to people and not serving
their interests and telling them to shut
up again and again calling them names
you know something you've got a
legitimate question like why should I
support a Warth a run shut up you know
calling me what you know I have four
children of draft age like why is that
not a fair question for me shut up
and you do that enough and I have
recourse because I have a platform um
but most people don't and if you tell
them to shut up enough like we don't
care that you care about gas prices in
your stupid pickup truck well some
people like their pickup trucks and they
use them for work and if it's not
affordable to fill it up that's a big
deal for them and if you're like shut up
climate change Pig you know your nephew
od's On fentel and nobody cares like if
you keep that up for long enough you
will make people r I and why wouldn't
they be radical actually and I'm so
insulated for most of it because I have
enough money and I'm not in debt and my
kids are grown and paid for and like I'm
I'm in a much easier position than most
people and I feel radical just watching
right and so why wouldn't they be on the
brink of of being unreasonable and it
doesn't need to be this way you don't
have to solve all of people's problems
like some problems are very hard to
solve and people know that there's no
magic button you press that end
inflation or stops fenel and everyone
knows that all you need to do is Express
the fact and do it sincerely that you
care you acknowledge these are big
problems but when the Speaker of the
House who I know is a nice guy from your
state the new Speaker of the House comes
in and the first thing he does is issue
a statement on behalf of foreign country
that's the most important thing I'm not
even against the statement but I'm just
saying like what bigger statement does
that make that's him Mikey Johnson yeah
and he's the speaker he is praise God
I'm damn Mikey he's a nice guy and I'm
not against him but I'm just saying like
if you think the welfare of another
country is the most important thing for
you as the one of the leaders of our
country third in line of the presidency
you have lost the thread son CU it's not
nothing is more important for the
leaders of our country than our country
and how it's 350 million people are
doing so I was enraged by that and
people like oh are you for Hamas of
course I'm not for Hamas at all I'm for
America actually I shouldn't even have
to answer that question are you for
Israel or Hamas I mean obviously I'm for
Israel Over Hamas but but that's
irrelevant I'm for America and no one
even asked that and I feel deep
resentment about that that the concerns
of this country are no concern right
right it feels like our concerns don't
even matter anymore that's why
it makes me wonder are we just a shell
company for Israel are we just a shell
company for China like where where are
we anymore
like are we just well there are a lot of
people who live here who really like it
here who were born I love it here well I
know you do and I'm just saying like it
doesn't have to be this way we you know
there are people there are hundreds of
millions of people whose ancestors are
buried here and they want to stay here
they don't have another passport and it
wouldn't be hard to Rally them and just
say like you're a Democrat you're a
republican you're this you're that but
we're all American and let's have a
conversation about what's best for our
country you would get people from all
sides being like that's right that's the
right convers we may not even agree but
that's the conversation we should be
having and if you don't do that I'm just
telling you you play with fire people go
crazy and I'm totally convinced that the
mass shootings we're seeing and the
massive spike in mental illness that
we're seeing which is leading to the
mass shootings these are manifestations
of the frustration the hopelessness that
people feel when they realize their
leaders don't care about them I believe
that I can't prove it yeah but I believe
it cuz I happen to live in a place with
a lot of you know people who are not
kind of succeeding in the modern world
and they're good people and they have
skills and they've been here their
families been here for hundreds of years
we should care about them I agree but
yeah I think our company our country has
been compromised by people that don't
care and they don't see value in that
and it feels like it's just um about uh
a bottom line or it's
about I don't know some goal that to me
seems so erroneous I can't even Fab
that you wouldn't have feelings like
when you're like that Sackler family
that's just let watching People's
children die just you can make money off
of a pill who cares what are you
e what are you going to get another like
half bathroom or something like what are
you going to get exactly like I just I
don't understand the goal sometimes of
um of some of that or why people would
think that selling someone out to such a
point where they don't have any purpose
where you take away their hope you know
uh we had a guy on here talk about
meaning this guy John Veri and he was
real interesting this guy uh is from
Canada and he just talks about meaning
and when people don't have like um when
they don't feel like they're supported
by I'm going to it up but if they
don't feel like they're part of a group
or they don't feel like um if they're
totally cut off from other people and
just floating around atomized and alone
it drives them crazy right you go crazy
yeah put solary confinement so You'
basically taken so much of America by
taking away like things that brought us
together and some of those things were
smaller towns like businesses in small
towns things that made people feel of
value you know my my father went to a um
you know my father his family was
mahogany Farmers they did wood and so I
think if your father went into the woods
in your town or whatever part of a
company they built tables they were
literally mahogany Farmers yeah and you
had a table at home and then you it was
your dad's company's table like we eat
our families we we build it in our town
there's some physical connection between
labor and reward and all theoretical and
digital and Zoom calls and yeah
yeah now it's just like do you want to
eat at this uh Chipotle sitgo
you know where they're selling gas and
burritos and you know and it just like
is that a thing but that's a
town hall of a lot of it's just now
everything has just been it's a Dollar
General in most towns and that's what it
is now you know it's like just we've
killed off a lot of that you know what's
interesting is you drive through I like
to hunt and fish so I've been in a lot
of small towns in America because that's
where the hunting and the fishing is
yeah and um some of these towns and
especially the county seats in rural
towns have beautiful cour houses
beautiful like somebody spent a lot of
money and a lot of time to make a
beautiful public building one of those
hasn't been built since the second world
war that is true probably since the 30s
since the depression wow your state
especially you've got a lot of great
public architecture in Louisiana none of
it has been built since huie long was
murdered Okay so so why is that and it's
been replaced by disposable garbage in
the dollar store I'm sorry to single
them out but they are a symbol of it
it's so intentionally ugly box stores
are so ugly you're like there's got to
be a purpose behind you know
architecture exists for a reason you're
sending a message when you build a
building when you build anything and the
message of box stores and dollar stores
and of public the DMV
is you mean nothing we're not going to
spend any time or any energy trying to
elevate you or please your senses or
build anything beautiful it's ugly on
purpose to let you know that you mean
nothing you do not count shut up and
Obey you're an animal actually and I
just feel like there's something very
profound about that the message that it
sends and everyone receives the message
whether they know it or not you go into
a DMV what's it telling
you wait your turn wait for your number
and then some Surly low IQ person like
you it's like I'm a Cien of this country
why I even have to have a driver's
license give me my papers and
let me get out of here how dare you
speak to me that way but you can't
because she's in charge the whole
experience is designed to degrade you
and make you
less powerful to take your self-respect
away uh I'm very upset by it oh the DMV
it's almost like they have a line if you
come out of the closet you get to go to
the front of the line you know I'd be
willing to do that yeah but that's the
kind of I'm saying it's like that's
how much they want to compromise who you
are or what you are but look at that
okay the drop ceiling like there's no
reason to have lighting like that it
doesn't cost more maybe to put some
lamps or or sconces or something there's
there's nothing more oppressive than a
drop ceiling with fluorescent lighting
and there's no reason to have that and
everything is made out of vinyl and
metal there's not one natural material
in there why don't have wooden benches
what would that cost extra train
stations used to have them but they
don't because the message there is all
this shit's disposed able it'll be in a
landfill in 5 years and so will you
everything about that is degrading to
the citizen and it's not an accident
we've been doing that since the day we
dropped the atomic bomb on Hiroshima
that is true since the end of the second
I mean I have a lot of theories about it
I you know I have no evidence to back up
any of my theories so I should just say
that I think that dropping the atomic
bomb on Japan convinced the US
government and the Western leaders more
broadly that they were God they had the
power to destroy whole cities new
nuclear power when weaponized is the
most powerful tool man's ever made MH
and it gave people the impression that
they were God and they lost all humility
and all love for their fellow citizens
they lost love for their fellow citizens
that's what our architecture post-war
architecture conveys I don't love you I
don't care about you the British
colonized whole countries India for
example yeah they didn't love the I mean
they love the but they thought the
Indians were lesser than them they did
they were racist in our current
understanding of that word but they
built train stations in say Kolkata or
Bombay that would blow your freaking
mind there's nothing is beautiful in the
United States the train stations they
built in the subcontinent in India oh
yeah stunning places right stunning so
like what does that tell you and these
were colonial train stations built for
Indian subjects right look at that but
they still had a lot of pride in what
they built they did but they they people
here do the one in
Mumbai the Mumbai train station is like
the most unbelievable I met a Pakistani
the other day
well that was part of India up until
1947 they have their own autonomy
now they do they have nuclear weapons
actually look at that look at that right
there wow look at that come on huh that
looks like I mean that's the train
station in Bombay Mumbai India oh yeah
I've been there and it just I sat there
and it's very poorly maintained the in
the Indian government has done nothing
to kind of preserve it unfortunately and
they've built a lot of garbage
architecture they stole from our
anti-human Architects but like what kind
of country would build something like
that a country that cared about pleasing
people right you look at that that
pleases you you want to keep staring at
it CU it's beautiful we've created
nothing of Beauty in the United States
in 80 years like what the hell Roy
lonstein and Andy Warhol that's Beauty
no it's not it's garbage Yeah Yeah it's
bootle you're getting me going baby am I
yeah oh yeah dude I like your attitude
well you know where there's great
architecture that blew my mind Milwaukee
the best down by the river dude
Milwaukee yes is a such a beautiful city
I totally agree with you I had no idea
have you tried Cleveland uh yeah I mean
Cleveland obviously is famously screwed
up Mistake by the lake but it's like
look at that right there so the Germans
built it Milwaukee was a German City
obviously it was oh yeah that's why the
beer was brewed there oh yeah yeah very
German City I love but we just and they
recreated Europe the best of Europe yeah
Cleveland definitely it was a bit of a
different experience I think I when I
was there um look at that look at that
building it's stunning imagine building
something like that and instead we buil
glass boxes that are lead certified and
it's like we've built nothing of value
nothing of permanence nothing we have
built in my lifetime will last and
rightly so there are Roman buildings and
arches right
that that are going to last longer Rome
pH fell in the fifth century and they're
still there and that will Outlast the
construction of a half these pet
goes or whatever it's true it's totally
true yeah sorry that know it's crazy
though but we just there's something
something happened and I think I think
that's the infection that starts to get
into the spirit of us you know and I
think that's the fight that's going on
inside of a lot of people make something
beautiful that's what we should be
telling kids like your job in life it's
not just working for the man and paying
the bills it's make one thing that's
beautiful that you are proud of that's
an expression of something good inside
you make it with your hands or with your
mouth but make it make something
beautiful I don't know why that's so and
by the way the Jo when you say something
that you think is that you think not
others you think is particularly funny
or insightful you're getting the truth
about something aren't you filled with
like this WOW doesn't that feel like
better than
anything yeah I think it feels like what
you're supposed to be doing yes that's
it exactly you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing what God made you
to do that's my feeling and we but
that's not advice that we give at all
it's like how to be an obedient get some
stupid degree at some stupid college to
be an obedient employee to some stupid
who runs it who's going to
mistreat you
yeah how do we
um what's new in your world what do you
what well I've gone crazy um what are
you doing now that's different with uh
you know you got on a Twitter right and
so I know that and congratulations thank
you I think because it's interesting
it's brave for people to get out of the
system a lot of people I was expelled
from the system but oh yeah yeah well
you know you got you got laid off from
everywhere was it cutbacks or why did
you cutbacks no not good I love I'm I'm
going to use that though there's
downsizing just downsizing yeah to I'm
being retrained I'm learning to code
actually they closed the plant I totally
get I was on third shift and there just
the demand was in Decline um I am going
to use that though next time why were
you
fired but you got out and you moved to
uh I was thrown out thrown out and I and
Elon called me the day that I my show
was cancelled and um and I was grateful
that he did and he called you huh had
you spoken to him before yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah he I had and uh and I really
liked him and um I'm not a technology
person to put it mildly like at all very
anology yep like almost on a crazy sort
of Ted kazinski way which is I'm not
defending it's so who handles tech for
for you then kind of the tech people I
don't they they live in Bangalore I
don't know their names just kidding no
we have really super smart people the
bangalorean the
bangalorian no um actually our
Mandalorian most of our staff from Fox
came um and elon's I we don't work for
Elon I'm just I'm a Twitter user like
everybody else but his all he said was
um I'm going to keep the platform open
you know and people with differing views
whether agree with them or not are
welcome on the platform and and that's
that's the guarantee that I wanted and
needed and so I've been super grateful I
mean that's all I've ever wanted by the
way um is to I've never been a I have
made some money but not never got crazy
rich but I never wanted to that wasn't
my goal at all I mean I guess I would
like to be richer I guess I don't know
what I I would do with it exactly well
it's now it almost looks like a sickness
too you know I think there should be a c
the the money acquisition thing yeah
there was a name for that actually
historically it was called greed yeah
and somewhere along the line we like
decide you weren't allowed to complain
about
greed and I don't really and because
you're against capitalism first of all
there is no capitalism in the United
States there's no free market okay the
government controls everything you can't
have a business without intersecting
with government and the government is
used by businesses to create Monopoly so
there's no free market so let's stop
lying about that second I am not against
capitalism I'm for competition I wish
capitalism would return to the United
States um but that doesn't mean that you
can't say if I've got a billion dollars
and I need 10 more that that's your sick
actually if that's your goal what would
you do with a billion dollars I mean I I
don't want a billion dollars not that
I'm in danger of getting it but if I was
I'd be like I don't want that because
then you spend your whole life worrying
about losing it and your existence
becomes about preserving money when your
existence should be about loving the
people around you and creating something
beautiful those are your those are your
jobs as a person in my opinion yeah well
how how could we put a cap on how much
money people are allowed to make I guess
people would find their way around it I
mean the way to do it is to say it out
loud again everything changes with words
articulate the truth it's not an attack
on capitalism which again does not exist
in the United States and I wish it did
to say it is ugly in fact it's a sin to
worship money yeah it is you should not
be worshiping money worship God worship
people around you worship nature even
but worshiping money is disgusting and
we should not compliment people who do
it we should instead criticize them and
say that's gross hey hedge fund manager
that's gross yeah I'm sorry I think that
no I think that too man I
remember like maybe a two years ago I it
was like the first time I'd really made
some money in my life and I thought and
I remember I was in my garage and I I
just was heartbroken man I would
remember calling my brother I was crying
and I was like it didn't make you happy
I thought I yeah because I well I didn't
even know it was money I didn't know if
it was popularity I don't know what had
happened but I'd got into a different
space SP in my career yeah I finally
knew I could pay my mortgage for the
year you know it just like and I thought
that that somehow in the back of my head
without me even realizing it I thought
that that would be the answer to
everything and when it wasn't it
yes killed me it's this is such but
nobody wants to hear that also from
somebody who's but it's the most
familiar thing I've ever heard it's like
I could tell you so many stories it just
made me so sad that I'd just been fooled
you know and even fooled by myself and
well getting what you want is one of the
saddest things that can happen happen to
you I mean when you're happiest when as
a man I'll speak for men cuz I am one
you have a clear mission for now for now
I mean I could totally change Oh They'll
change I get a better spot at the DMV
Tucker it does change you there's
something going on yeah in the water
baby and that's why I if I could take a
break yeah to just promote my
non-sponsors
in and this these are threes and I
normally use sixes but I appreciate the
gesture but I do think nicotine does
keep your testosterone levels up really
I'd do one of those suppositories I'm
not doing a big one or anything you know
I mean maybe during the holidays I would
it's not like an expander it's just a
regular okay I would do something small
you know just pop a bead in or something
you know if I'm going to be at the
Ballpark you know I do probably just
something half a gram or whatever
milligrams I don't know what it comes in
three milligrams yeah dude but but
getting what you want succeeding you
know that's when men fall apart
but then also I think that there were
more opportunities for success in the
past and there was more opportunities to
feel value in the past like I remember
when I was a kid we used to get our name
in the paper and it made you feel so
good like your local baseball scho right
and like even if you lost they
put your last name i 0 for four right
cried even though put cried like in
parenthesis you're like yeah dude
like at least I'm on the stat sheet they
caught you crying yeah I mean I had an
appendectomy right and the guy who I
think was closet or whatever was our Co
was like assistant coach or whatever and
he was screaming at me to get to third
base and literally my appendix had burst
so I can you show me on the doll where
this
happened dude I remember we had a dude
bus there's something here I can feel it
oh bro this guy's screaming at me to get
to Third Base my appendix burst I'm
laying in the dirt right and
that's a sign of our country
nowadays they're like get to
Third Base you're like I have sepsis
and nobody cares man but they
still put you in the stat sheet you know
0 for four
um yeah I think oh we had a dude who was
touching players and they just called
him and they're like look you can't keep
coaching if you're going to touch
players that touching him like in an
affirming way uh I think just extra
affirming like two two affirming like
overhand you're affirming but once you
turn the hand this way I totally agreee
reach around not affirming yeah if
you're doing that yeah from the that's
totally totally age that's una affirming
dude um what do you think about where do
we go does does Bobby Kennedy Jr have
any chance does a third party have any
chance these days no a third third party
can affect the outcome for sure but the
system is I mean this could change with
time but the system it's it's so it's
shown no sign of changing I can bore you
for hours but you know Ross per ran in '
92 and then '96 you know and he got
Clinton elected ears that was the
campaign I think fear the ears I never
heard that I remember made it up that
was good thanks but he and he actually
was was kind of impressive in he was a
real smart guy huh he was he was and he
said a lot of things that turned out to
be true but of course he was attacked as
some kind of crazy person but um
including by me I should say damn really
yeah I was used as a tool do you even
notice you're a tool when you're a to
like that for the for the no wow I was
20 I was in my early 20s and I was right
writing I was covering first of all
people in the early 20s should not be
covering anything other than like kids
with appendectomies in baseball like
that that right shouldn't be covering
National politics in your T like what do
you know you don't know so you
shouldn't be rendering judg other 100%
100% you know FFA events or whatever but
not not politics but anyway I was and I
attacked him as a crazy person and I was
used by the person I was working for
who's still a public person and TR a
dishonest person but anyway whatever
leave if it's Chuck Schumer to say it
more dishonest than Chuck Schumer wow
yeah but anyway H I can't even get into
it but uh the point is he got 23% or
whatever I think it was 23 that year in
looss pero did oh yeah wow oh dude
because he was running basically on pre
you sort of a pre-trump more restrained
more academic you know less you know
less Trump but but the idea was the same
like manufacturing is dying and it's
going to wreck the country we need to
make things stuff like that bush perau
and dakus no who was that no dakus was
88 it was Bush perau and Bill Clinton
wow who was then the governor of
Arkansas 1992 was the first race I
covered and pero did really well despite
massive hostility from the media because
of course they were
protecting yeah you know their bosses
estment exactly that's exactly but I
didn't perceive any of 18.9% he got what
did he get 18.9 sorry 19% I'm
embarrassed did he affect the outcome of
that race oh well he he won it for
Clinton I mean Clinton won it as you see
on the page at 43 43% absolutely if Pro
didn't win do you think that bush wins
that of course yeah oh absolutely he
took from Bush yeah who is Kennedy taken
from what do you think Trump you think
of course there's no person who's
thinking hm I'm going to vote either for
Joe Biden or Bobby Kennedy I have some
friends that are no way I swear really I
have some friends that are that have
known Bobby I mean these are people that
have known Bobby Kennedy for a long time
and but who are Democrats who are like
this is my guy the only reason you would
vote for Joe Biden is because you
believe their safety and numbers you're
voting for the party you're not
obviously I'm not attacking Biden but
you're not voting for Biden you're
voting for the Democratic party because
you think when they have more power
you're safer richer or whatever that's
the only reason and Bobby Kennedy man I
mean I've never seen anybody get right
to the core
issues affecting the country the way he
has and I don't agree with him on
everything but I mean he names names I
mean in a big way yeah that's why I love
him I think well I just think he can
he doesn't know I I don't feel like
he's in anybody's pocket do you feel
like lowkey there's some party that's
like planted him in there people say
that but that's that's crazy I
think I I mean I feel like I know Bobby
very well and I I am totally convinced
just on a human level that he is an
honest person too and I don't think that
he would do that and um I just have to
ask are there people in his orbit who
would do that I believe yes is the
answer but I don't think he knows better
has anything to do with it I think he's
totally sincere he's certainly not in
anyone's pocket I mean the guy could be
his name is Bobby Kennedy he's the son
of oh he could do whatever he could he
could do whatever he could do whatever
and and he has done he's done a ton of
great stuff of his life he has but I'm
just saying it's very easy to be loved
by everybody and to just it's very easy
to make when everyone loves you Bobby
Kennedy could have an infinitely easier
life than the one he's chosen he's doing
this because he sincerely believes it
look at that right and he's under threat
I mean I was with him on the street the
other day this week in Washington and
the security people around him were very
nervous oh he was not nervous at all but
they were anyway the point is I think
Bobby's totally sincere but he is giving
a massive middle finger to The
Establishment like almost as
aggressively as I've ever seen anybody
why can't we get him to a level because
what percent does he have to get oh I
guess I don't we don't know because you
don't know what get plurality you know
we need to get more than the other two
and unfortunately the system is set up
where it's hard for a third party guy to
get on all ballots I mean they've rigged
the system against a third party
challenge because they don't want that
who has rigged the system both of the
parties both both of the parties yeah of
course of course they don't I mean once
you have power what's your number one
goal it's preserving it and preventing
people from challenging you you know of
course when a revolution what city
should we meet up
in uh well if there is a revolution and
I pray there isn't because they never
end well but if there is but it'll be
fun huh for like the first 20
minutes when you actually storm the
basal and free the prisoners or whatever
yeah hang your homemade flag from the
roof of the capital or whatever like you
burn the news networks is the first
thing you'd have to do so that'd be the
fun part of the Revolution think that'd
be that that would be definitely be the
fun part but then it gets then you have
like show trials and Salmons and you
have like all the downside but whatever
I'm not in church so if that happens I
will be so deep in the woods surrounded
by my dogs and I'll say it Firearms um
probably not going to hear from me look
let's just pretend one of your dogs is
named
Firearms I actually have a dog call
firearm yeah I have AK and 47 whatever
you have dude I got bow I got Arrow I
got whatever you know I got all my
weapons in the woods with me um but and
you can even just text me and just let
me know where you're going to be
but I think about that you know what's
Wild is I think about that sometimes but
you're going to be in La no I won't be I
live in Nashville oh you don't live in
LA no I live in a place where if
somebody is being weird you can shoot
them um okay because if you're in La you
just get eaten yeah oh well here's a
move you would do in LA you would get in
a boat and go off the shore that would
be the first move and let the other
having grown up on the Pacific let me
just say it's a little bigger than the
chunk of funky River wherever you you're
from okay a super big ocean yeah also
Ben and Jerry's while we're at it I
want to say that but go on they're
Marxist is it called chunky monkey
what's the name of your River uh chauna
Chun but I love that dude that's the
greatest name ever but the Pacific goes
on uh forever and then you make it to
Hawaii like six days later in your
Boston wher yeah right well if you've
been lost to se for six days you deserve
to show up in Hawaii I think it's easy
to miss Hawaii though in the middle of
the Pacific you could yeah that's a long
way to Thailand you imagine they pick
you up they're like you you it this
close to Hawai you're like what the
I let my wife Drive no the Pacific is
not a good Escape Plan at all no because
South you have you know Baja Sonata
right right that's going to be a little
chaotic it always is yeah from Los
Angeles to what the the Arctic Circle I
mean that's just like nothing it's like
Alaska like there's kind of nowhere to
go yeah um but you know you get in the
woods deep in there yeah you got a shot
you got a shot and Radley up in there
with a couple of pups 100% you go full
Boo Radley oh live in the hollow of a
tree yeah that's it I love that me too
man it sounds exciting but I think
people start to think that way how and
that's a sad it's interesting because
that thought just comes in my head
sometimes I've thought about asking
people I know I thought about asking Joe
Rogan where do we meet
up if gets weird and i' never used
to think that I think Joe's going to
leave his house right he might not but I
think everybody's got a little bit of a
place you know I think some people are
thinking maybe could be I think you want
to do mountainous so I think you go Salt
Lake or Denver you know Broncos suck but
so I don't know if I'd go there Utah at
least doesn't have a team um I don't
know but you start to think about that
you want to get up to sea level you know
you don't want nature beating you so you
don't want to drown out you don't want
to be in John's toown or
something or whatever that place is
Johnstown or Jonestown or Jonestown both
of them both of them bad bad bad purple
Kool-Aid overflowing Rivers um have you
don't want to go anywhere I think is the
truth you don't want to go anywhere you
don't want to you don't want to travel
if things go go sideways I don't I don't
think you want to be on the road I mean
I that's a good point the two times I've
been in places for brief periods where
you know there really was no Authority
MH um what did that feel like and where
was it
one was at Katrina right after the storm
in New Orleans wow you were down there H
bro I was and the other was in Baghdad
in December of 03 when it kind of like
started to get I felt out of hand and
which one was more hectic you
think well back dead but I but for the
United States I really no one ever says
this I really feel like Katrina was like
was almost unbelievable how chaotic it
was oh yeah oh for real I mean I yeah I
could bore you but oh I've been at a
game when the saints are losing
to the falcon and it gets hectic
enough there is no one there to call
like period and then people start
behaving in ways that are ridiculous and
I saw I saw that with my own eyes and
dead people and people getting shot like
I saw it I'm not guessing and I was just
like this cannot be America like I
always thought if something bad happened
there would be like you just like call
some special number and like dad comes
and restores Order no no at all the
police were looting I saw it police were
looting during Katrina so so that's um
anyway whatever my point is I don't
think you want to travel too much if you
can help it yeah you know it's better to
be in a place where you're just like
this is my place and I'm defending it
with these Firearms but the SEC until
things calm down you know until like
electricity is restored after the MP
attack or whatever yeah because that's
what's going to happen you there be a
nuclear attack no there's going to be
you know it's pretty easy to take down a
society that's digital oh yeah once you
unplug that and then when there's but
but that's a crazy feeling when you're
like okay cuz your first thought is let
me call somebody nope your phone isn't
going to work no calling no oil through
the pipelines no food deliver God's
going to have the busiest afternoon no
Airlines no one on the roads dams fail
like it all you know if you've if you've
put everything online which cu the
people who run our country are so stupid
they've actually done
that you are so vulnerable that it's
unbelievable and you're using chinesee
servers and switchers and like at that
point you have no you don't need to drop
a nuke on anybody yeah yeah first of all
sh do not nuke you don't need to you
don't need to let us at least enjoy the
mystery of it for a little while too but
people are so that doesn't mean just no
door Dash that means no anything and
people one thing I've noticed in both
the places I've been no Stacy Dash
either huh that you know no Stacy
Dash you can't call any of your call
girls from the interstate God dude what
if they start showing you're like they
will they'll be seeking Refuge at your
place remember me you tip me for no
service seeking Refuge
reignment um that was a tough play on
words that a good one though thank you
dude um but I think yeah but you
wouldn't be able to use money anywhere
no that's going to become no Val like
it's just it's weird we're having this
conversation but even as me listening to
you talk I am my brain I think is
recording this because it feels it could
be plausible all you need is a couple of
cops to be like you know what these
people as well I'm not going to
quit def I'm not going to quit
blockading or attacking these people who
I know are really struggling when I'm
going home tonight and being one of them
100% And by the way my kids my kids are
at home and there's now this happened in
New Orleans during Katrina is cops and I
give them all the benefit of the doubt
you know some of them you do have some
criminal cops down there but you also
have good guys too you know and the good
guys are like I'm sorry I got a wife and
kids at home like I'm not and people
going nuts the thing that I noticed was
it took like zero time from when
Authority disappeared for people to get
super afraid for the Predators to come
out and start praying on people and for
everything just to fall apart everything
yeah and if you unplug this country and
by the way once you decide you're going
to go to war with Iran as we've
apparently the morons who run our
country have decided that is I mean a
very likely outcome that they're going
to do something like that really ABS
absolutely
everyone's like oh they they could send
an ICBM or whatever no it's why would
they bother to throw a missile at the
United States across the ocean when they
could unplug the country and then you
have real casualties Mass casualties and
mass chaos like true true chaos oh yeah
people are not prepared for this they
haven't thought it through our leaders
have not prepared them for it at all
it's like oh it's on your iPhone we
don't have an iPhone and there's no
electricity and there's no water
and there's no way to get anywhere yeah
come on dude and that could happen
that's not science fiction like that
could happen soon and we're not ready
for it and as you said it's not a
cohesive country people are not like oh
I'm going to help my neighbors you don't
know who your neighbors are they may not
speak the same language well you're
certainly not going to also help your
government so that's going to be the
weird thing when the government's like
people do this it's you it you might if
you're a lot of people be like you
I don't trust you totally and people
have not seen chaos they don't know what
chaos looks like we don't like when
people imagine War they imagine you know
two lines against each other lobbing
artillery shells or rifle fire at each
other there's a certain order to that
and people can can handle it you know
it's dangerous but I can handle it it
makes sense to me it's orderly it's
geometric chaos is completely different
from that chaos is like you have no
freaking idea what's happening who's on
your side who's not who's a threat who
isn't where things are going people are
not designed for that people can't
handle chaos and they go crazy and I've
only as I said had a taste of this a
couple of times but enough to learn
chaos is the one thing you have to avoid
because that's when people become
animals and really start behaving in
ways that are inconceivable to civilize
people oh we're going to turn into
middle monkeys real fast or we're gonna
like in minutes yeah oh yeah bro dude I
was at a Dave and Busters one time right
I'm not even joking power goes
out dude did you eat anyone bro it was
whacka everyone in that dude
people were beating the there was it was
complete darkness right and people yeah
you're feeling around for
whatever you know birthday cake or
whatever you're you know like you don't
even know what's going on yeah but that
was crazy that's a Dave and Busters I
know you know um so what is your plans
now like you've already you're on
Twitter you're in a free space as much
as we have in in today's society you're
in a free space for free speech what
else do you is there like we have some
some plans I mean some of them I mean if
I'm being honest include territorial
expansion we're going to invade Canada
oh dude they'll just knock no pillow
fight you take them in a second um no I
mean I I I just want to continue doing
what we're doing which is just you know
say say things that can't be said in
other places bring facts that maybe
people haven't heard with a spirit of
humility you know if you I'm having
spent my whole life in Washington most
of it 35 years I'm very I know it's I
can't believe I did but you know what I
think a lot of people were glad that
somebody was there you know it's nice to
see people that get out of a space
because then they're when you're not as
compromis when people don't seem as
compromise it's totally right no it's
totally true but I didn't realize just
how controlled my brain was by it when I
was in it because you don't right but um
but anyway but I've been around a lot of
people who set out like with these
grandiose plans I'm going to change the
world the those people invariably 100%
of the time make the world worse so like
you know approach every task with the
knowledge I have no real idea what I'm
doing I don't know the long-term
consequences of this I probably can't
fix every problem I'm just going to try
my best with humility you know to make
things slightly better that's my goal
make things slightly better but anyone
who tells you if we pass this
legislation we're going to fix
everything we're going to fix healthc
care forever said Barack Obama in 2010
as soon as he said that I was like I
don't even know much about Healthcare
I'm hardly an expert but I was like the
second you tell me you're going to fix
something as complicated as you know one
of the entire US economy in one piece of
legislation you yeah cuz you're
lying actually cuz that's impossible and
it turned out they made it worse of of
course so I don't want to do that not
that I even have the power to but I just
want to you know I just want to tell the
truth and and do it without being told
not to and I think that we can and
Tucker on X is your show y right Y and
do you guys have will you do you think
would you ever do a show with a partner
you think or anything like that I'm not
going to pit you an idea I'm just uh
because that's usually the predecessor
question of like somebody trying to pit
you an idea but do you think about that
sort of thing like do you have I well I
mean I have a million people I would
like to to work with I mean you know I
like to interview people actually and a
lot and I really try to be quiet while I
interview them cuz I'm a compulsive
talker obviously but I'd like a respit
from that where I can just like listen
so I like to we will have a lot of
people on and we have and we'll have a
lot of recurring guests but yeah we have
all we're making a bunch of
documentaries and doing stuff like that
um so like a production company kind of
more like are you expanding in that
sense M yep like um what is that one
bapiro has one outkick is a company is
that a company daily wire I don't know
know what outkick is I have a friend who
um who works there outkick I think it
was football and then they
uh okay does Jason does Jason still work
there do you know Jason Whitlock yeah I
do know Jason Whitlock I met him one
time I so I love Jason Whitlock he's a
really neat guy he seemed very friendly
I didn't get to talk to him much he's a
great guy and very deep he's not a
shallow person at all he's the kind of
person when you're talking to him
whitlock's oh there he is right there
Whitlock will say things and you're like
like wait what I'm sorry I just want to
have like a super shallow conversation
like how are you I'm great how are you
and he'll cuz I'm shallow in some ways
and he he'll like he doesn't he doesn't
think like that or talk like that he'll
sort like super heavy stuff out there
and it's cool that'd be interesting
sometimes I want to have deeper
conversations with people but I think I
get afraid to get into them or I don't
know how to get into them without
seeming like I'm being uh obtrusive or I
don't know with him you don't have to
worry cuz he does it he's okay with it
yeah well he just goes there immediately
goes
there um I like that about him do you uh
do do you ever get asked and then we'll
wrap up because I know you've been here
for a while and thanks for your time I
love it um do you ever get asked to
bring people over to Twitter like is
there like no movement because I know
John Stewart just had a show with apple
right was that
recently where he cancelled yeah he had
a show with apple John Stewart John
Stewart the guy from The Daily Show from
the Daily Show John Stewart show on
Apple is ending Mr Stewart and and sorry
Apple are parting ways because of
creative differences over I didn't even
know he had a show on Apple so it shows
you what I know people with the
knowledge um but they had a disagreement
about the episodes the type of episodes
he wanted to do he wanted to do episodes
on can we move it down okay according to
Hol reporter head of IT decision the end
Apple approached Stuart directly and
expressed its need for the host and his
team to be aligned with the company's
views on topics discussed
rather than falling in line when Apple
threatened to cancel the show Stuart
reportedly decided to walk uh Stuart
intended discussions of artificial
intelligence and China were a major
concern for Apple why would they be
concerned with him having episodes like
that I mean we're assuming that's true I
I hope it's true that's a noble reason
to leave you know if you think there's
something really important you want to
cover and your boss says no it's a good
reason to quit so I hope that that's
right was there another time you almost
quit before you got laid off show I mean
I didn't know even know that show
existed so I don't think it was doing
well I don't think so yeah um and Stuart
obviously a talented guy I I knew him
you know yeah he's kind of beloved 25
years ago yeah he I always thought he
was talented he definitely did what I
think everyone does at some point and
it's important to come out of it and
start to mistake yourself for like a
Messianic figure and just be like no I'm
I'm just a guy like it's so important
and I I've done that so I I've been
there oh yeah your ego is the first
thing to grow 100% And it's very scary
you're like dang does God have some
special reason for me no you will
humiliate yourself you will humiliate
yourself and you'll destroy yourself you
will lose the respect of your wife and
your friends if you don't pull back from
that yeah and just remember I am an
and if you don't believe that
next time you get out of the shower walk
in front of the mirror and look look at
yourself and be like am I really
impressive no not really oh yeah yeah I
I saw it this morning did you yeah what'
you
think yeah right yeah so yeah right
exactly so like it's important to do
that you know what I mean that will keep
you from thinking you're the Messiah I
don't think he has any mirrors in his
house um any other question that or
anything you wanted to talk about Tu no
okay I know you share everything on your
own show why just share everything in
general yeah yeah I've enjoyed the hell
out of yeah man it's been a lot of fun
I've had a great time yeah me too I
appreciate it you're the only person
I've talked to in the last well probably
ever who one of my kids will be
impressed
by they're not impressed at all yeah
they're impressed by you I don't know
why you've obviously got some sort of
sort of weird magic power over younger
people I don't and I don't know anything
about that you don't abuse it well no
that's thing okay good I just they not
going to start a Children's Crusade or
anything they came after our industry a
couple years ago you know oh I didn't
mean anything creepy okay good no yeah
yeah yeah and I only know adult women
and um oh the the old women like you no
I just only know people that are legally
adults well of course okay that's all
I'm saying dude because yeah immediately
like you know that I remember the New
York Times Like hunted down half of our
industry you know like finding noticed I
noticed yeah just that vague stuff where
comes up and I think there are a lot of
creepy comedians but not as many as
there are in journalism yes there's some
creatures in journalism dude what
happened remember the guy who Jered off
in the zoom meeting and then they
brought him back on for the interview
and he sat there and he's like oh you
got cut whacking off and a zoom
interview I mean it just shows you his
name is Jeff tubin and you know not a
stupid guy actually I know him and um I
have worked with him but he's oh yeah
but his desire to be on television
trumps everything else oh like if I said
to you you know if that happened you'd
be like you know what I'm just kind of
out I'm going to do something you know
what I mean I'll find something know
I've had issues with it right yeah well
you but you said you have them under
control you're not compulsive no I'm
doing great just habitual but not a
problem yeah just on a full moon
but imagine if you're Jeff tubin to sit
there with this female anchor on Fox and
talk about that it's like there's no
shame that you won't bear there's no
you won't eat just to be on
television and I I obviously had no
respect for Jeff tubin anyway because I
know him um but I had even less uh after
that I mean that was weird how God will
give you your gifts you don't
know what they're going to be wrapped in
it's like all wanted to be was on camera
I know and just like there you got to
want the right things you know what I
mean I think you got to get real
specific with God bro cuz he's busy I
totally agree and last thing I'll say is
I think it's so important if you are
publicly humiliated and I have certainly
been um and he was of course too it can
be a great thing that's a great thing
yeah and you should treat it that way
and be grateful for it you know that
this is keeping me from becoming an even
worse wor person that I might otherwise
have been there's nothing worse than a
man who spent his entire adult life
succeeding and never being humiliated
they become unbearable they talk only
about themselves they can't bear to
listen to you every time you talk
they're holding their breath until you
stop so they can start up again they
become true narcissists and I just hope
for Jeff tubin who's really an
actually I'm just saying um I don't know
him but I do I do so I to say he's like
he's an yeah he is but he may be
less of one now yeah actually and and
I've certainly been an a lot so
I I'm not judging you know but I do it
so I I have high hopes for him yeah
caught whacking off there's a massive
upside potentially oh yeah dude I mean
definitely there's no yeah that guy
definitely likes
jerking but um yeah anyway uh tuger
Carlson thanks so much dude it was
interesting and I really appreciate your
time I really do I did and thank you for
the Zen all right yeah you bet brother I
might do one later
see now I'm just floating on the breeze
and I feel I'm falling like these leaves
I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my life
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to
take